et vendredi à minuit le texte arrive en
séance ici même dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat à partir du 2 mars jusqu'à a
priori au 12 mars la réforme des
retraites d'ailleurs dont il va être
question pendant cette séance question
gouvernement sur les 17 questions que
l'on va suivre dans quelques secondes on
aura deux questions sur cette réforme
dont une posée en milieu de séance ce
sera la 10e question posée par elle
Sabine van eygues une question consacrée
aux 1200 euros un mirage selon le PS et
alors que également le PS va demander à
ce que le gouvernement écoute la
mobilisation dans la rue on verra donc
quelle sera et bien la réponse du
gouvernement à ce moment on a aussi deux
autres thèmes majeurs avec notamment la
question des fermetures de classe dans
les écoles ou encore deux questions sur
l'arcom c'est parti pour cette séance la
séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu l'observation il y en
a-t-il en séance
je n'envoie point le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direction Public Sénat
issure notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect des uns et les
autres et au respect du temps de parole
je vais donner immédiatement la parole
au président Pierre Laurent pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste vous avez la parole monsieur
le président
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre non content de mettre le pays
dans la rue et bientôt à l'arrêt sur les
retraites votre gouvernement vient de
provoquer un nouveau vent de colère
contre la suppression de postes et de
classe dans l'éducation nationale par an
élève et enseignants ont découvert en
janvier une carte scolaire actant sans
concertation mille suppressions de poste
en primaire et 500 dans le secondaire et
les mobilisations se multiplient un peu
partout à la rentrée dernière vous
peignez à mettre un enseignant devant
chaque classe allant jusqu'à recruter à
la va-vite fin août sur Job Dating des
enseignants précaires 4 mois plus tard
vous nous dites qu'il y a trop
d'enseignants et de classe en France
pouvez-vous nous expliquer ce tour de
passe-passe
dans de nombreux départements les
établissements auraient plus sont les
premiers touchés à Paris c'est une
véritable saignée
337 postes et 240 classes supprimées
cela fait suite en plus au scandale de
la fermeture de cette lycées
professionnels parisiens décidez par
Valérie Pécresse avec l'aval du
ministère mais le problème n'est pas
limité à la capitale les banlieues comme
les zones rurales sont durement frappées
entendez-vous l'appel des mers ruraux
qui demandent un moratoire immédiat sur
les fermetures de classe et d'écoles
monsieur le ministre pendant la coïd le
gouvernement nous explique avec le temps
éducatif devait être protégés comme la
prunelle de nos yeux aujourd'hui vous
jetez tout ça aux oubliettes l'éducation
nationale redevient une cible
prioritaire des coûts budgétaires
alors les mêmes dogmatismes budgétaires
ont fabriqué les pénuries et les déserts
médicaux dont nous souffrons aujourd'hui
dans tout le pays monsieur le ministre
allez-vous créer les pénuries et les
déserts éducatifs de demain
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur peuple
merci monsieur le Président de Mesdames
et Messieurs le et sénateurs monsieur le
Président Laurent j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire dans cette
hémicycle nous allons perdre environ 500
000 élèves dans les 5 années à venir et
la situation est plus aiguë encore à
Paris puisque la baisse de la natalité
se combine au déménagement hors de Paris
des familles et notamment des familles
avec des jeunes enfants alors quelle est
la réalité de la situation à Paris
permettez-moi trois données la première
c'est le nombre la diminution du nombre
d'élèves à Paris elle est de moins 20%
ces 10 dernières années et cela va
continuer dans les cinq années à venir
19,8 c'est le nombre d'élèves moyens par
classe à Paris il est de 21,7
au niveau national enfin Paris bénéficie
d'un maillage des écoles qui est le plus
dense de France avec un réseau de
transport sans équivalence sur le
territoire français nos critères pour
assurer la répartition des postes sur le
territoire sont simples équité et
universalité ma responsabilité c'est
bien celle de l'équité territoriale et
celle-ci effectivement amène à faire des
choix des choix pour que le service
public d'éducation soit préservé sur le
territoire français des choix pour que
nos professeurs soient mieux rémunérés
la hausse du budget de l'Éducation
nationale elle est de 6,5% cette année
pour mémoire elle était de 2% en moyenne
annuelle entre 2012 et 2017 alors
monsieur le Président il ne s'agit pas
d'opposer les territoires les uns aux
autres mais nous devons considérer avec
justesse l'ensemble des situations et de
prendre la hauteur de vue pour assurer à
tous les meilleures conditions
d'éducation
Monsieur Laurent quelques secondes
oui il faut pas opposer les territoires
mais c'est exactement ce que vous venez
de faire pour vous la calculette elle
fonctionne toujours dans le même sens
vous utilisez toujours le règlement de
la démocratie vous le connaissez qu'à la
hausse qu'à la baisse mais jamais à la
hausse contre la question se pose donc
vous devriez revoir vos calculs parce
que dans beaucoup de territoires la
colère va continuer à monter sur ce
sujet
donner la parole à notre collègue Xavier
yakovelli pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre comme vous le savez les Jeux
Olympiques approchent et les transports
en Île-de-France seront une question
centrale aujourd'hui le réseau est
surchargé par les milliers de
Franciliens qui prennent les transports
véritable galères au quotidien entre
retard suppression ou encore trainé
certains ou même certaines posent même
clairement la question de notre capacité
à accueillir cet événement cette semaine
vous avez visité le chantier Éole ce
grand projet du prolongement du RER E
vers l'ouest parisien et je me félicite
que l'État puisse accompagner la région
Île-de-France sur ses projets mais
aujourd'hui l'État ne peut pas tout
faire et je rappelle que la compétence
transport était avant tout une
compétence de la région car au-delà des
Jeux Olympiques c'est l'ensemble du
financement des transports en
Île-de-France qu'il faudrait repenser
dès 2024 c'est-à-dire demain 600
millions d'euros m'encreront à l'appel
pour financer le fonctionnement des
nouvelles lignes actuellement en
chantier le réseau Francilia va donc en
effet doublé d'ici 2030 et on estime à
1,3 milliards les besoins de financement
il y a deux ans la chambre régionale des
comptes tirez déjà la solette d'alarme
sur la gestion inadaptée et
déséquilibrée d'Île-de-France mobilité
l'endettement de cette opérateur après
avoir été multiplié par 7 entre 2013 et
2018 a encore augmenté de 64 % pour la
seule année 2022 face aux difficultés
accumulées en décembre dernier l'État
est à nouveau venu au secours
d'Île-de-France mobilité en abondant son
budget de 200 millions d'euros et malgré
cela malgré cela Île-de-France mobilité
a décidé d'augmenter le prix du Pass
Navigo pour un service qui continue de
se dégrader et notamment dans le RER B
et D
alors il y a quelques semaines chers
collègues mais oui il y a quelques
semaines c'est tenu une conférence sur
le financement des transports
franciliens monsieur le ministre qu'elle
piste ont été retenus pour trouver une
solution de long terme permettant aux
transports francilien d'être à la fois
financé d'accueillir correctement des
millions de visiteurs et permettent aux
faux signes qui travaillent d'avoir des
transports à l'heure suffisant et de
qualité je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur
Clément vaut le ministre délégué chargé
des transports monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président et mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur yakovelli vous avez la question
spécifique d'abord des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques nous avons décidé de
mettre en place au niveau de l'État je
préside cet instant avec Amélie ou de la
Castéra un comité stratégique des
mobilités pour regrouper toutes les 6
semaines tous les acteurs dont la région
Île-de-France bien sûr pour faire
avancer nos chantiers notamment les
grands projets d'infrastructures qui
devront être prêts pour les Jeux
Olympiques et bien bien évidemment
bénéficier aux Franciliens bien au-delà
des Jeux Olympiques c'est lequel
notamment du chantier Eole et je me
félicite que collectivement nous ayons
trouvé un accord de financement sur les
surcos pour assurer son fonctionnement
pour une première branche dès le
printemps prochain ce projet financé
pour moitié par l'État nous avons trouvé
cet accord consensuel c'est dans cet
esprit que je crois que nous devons
avancer globalement sur les transports
franciliens vous avez soulevé un stand
de difficulté de financement je veux
quand même rappeler d'où nous partons je
rappelle que nous avons un contrat de
plan état région qui est en train de se
terminer l'État finance en Île-de-France
40% des besoins c'est un inédit en
France pendant la crise de la covid nous
avons permis de verser 2 milliards
d'euros d'avance remboursables à la
région de France c'était nécessaire là
aussi il n'y a aucun équivalent en
France et je pense que c'était important
cela mérite d'être rappelé j'ai décidé
le Parlement à voter dans le budget pour
2023 200 millions d'aide exceptionnelles
c'est aussi totalement sans comparaison
en France pour l'île de France pour
l'année 2023 il faut que nous me
trouvions maintenant une méthode et un
accord durable pour le financement les
transports en ligue de France c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec Valérie
Pécresse nous avons qu'au président des
Assises du financement des transports
franciliens je pense que c'était une
bonne initiative des pistes ont été
évoquées au début du mois de la fin du
mois de janvier pardon et nous sommes
mis d'accord je crois qu'il faut nous en
tenir à cette méthode loin des
polémiques ou des micro-tendus pour
avoir dès le mois d'avril un diagnostic
partagé sur les besoins et les pistes de
financement et avant l'été donc avant le
budget qui sera soumis au Parlement des
pistes de financement précises pour
assurer dans la durée le financement de
l'ex des lignes du Grand Paris Express
qui font là aussi l'objet d'un effort
sans précédent de l'État je crois que
c'est dans cet esprit de responsabilité
qu'on doit ensemble avancer désormais
merci la parole est à notre collègue
guillau Ghislaine Pantel pour notre
collègue Franck Montaugé par delémois
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
monsieur le Président chers collègues
madame la Première ministre je dis
dernier sur la proposition du groupe
socialiste l'Assemblée nationale s'est
prononcé par 205 voix pour et une contre
en faveur de la nationalisation d'EDF et
de l'incessibilité de son capital détenu
par l'État EDF ne pourrait donc plus
être démantelé livré au marché à la
découpe et parce que les filets de
sécurité que vous avez mis en place sont
très insuffisants pour sauver les
entreprises souvent artisanales comme
les boulangers le texte de leur
permettrait à toutes d'accéder au tarif
régulé courageusement les députés du
parti gouvernemental ont quitté
l'hémicycle au moment du vote de ce
texte ce qui en dit long d'abord sur
leur respect de la démocratie
parlementaire mais plus profondément
encore madame la Première ministre cette
attitude est le reflet de l'impensé
politique du gouvernement à l'égard de
votre projet industriel pour EDF comme
de vos objectifs concrets de la forme du
marché de l'électricité dans l'intérêt
général des Français et de toutes nos
entreprises madame la Première ministre
si ce texte qui est maintenant sur le
bureau du Sénat nous vous convient pas
quelles sont vos propositions
alternatives pour EDF comment
entendez-vous répondre immédiatement aux
difficultés de beaucoup d'entreprises
dont l'existence est en jeu et les
dirigeants avec leur salarié dans un
grand désarroi
pour vous répondre
la parole des communistes de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Franck motoger je vais vous
dire le fond de ma conviction sur ce
texte
je ne vois pas ce qu'il rapporte
mais je vois très bien ce qu'il coûte 18
milliards d'euros je pense qu'il
rapporte parce que nous avons engagé la
prise de participation de DF par l'État
à hauteur de 100% que nous détenons au
moment où je vous parle
96% des titres donc je ne vois pas à
quoi ça sert de faire un texte de loi
pour nationaliser EDF alors que l'État
va avoir 100% des titres d'ici quelques
semaines et que nous en avons déjà 96%
alors vous me dites c'est le projet
Hercule vous allez vouloir démonter le
DF mais dans quelle langue faudra-t-il
dire et répéter que le projet Hercule
est mort et enterré et que nous voulons
préserver l'unité de DF pourquoi
voulez-vous que nous reprenions les
titres de déesse et maîtriser à 100%
cette entreprise pour en faire un grand
service public si c'était pour
démanteler derrière l'entreprise cela
n'aurait absolument aucun sens je veux
que les choses soient claires et
entendues quand à ce qu'elle coûte 18
milliards d'euros moi je veux bien qu'on
est tendre comme le propose cette
proposition de loi l'ensemble des tarifs
réguliers électricité non seulement très
petites entreprises non seulement petits
entreprises mais aussi au PME monsieur
aux entreprises de taille intermédiaires
comme vous le proposez c'est à dire
quasiment tout le tissu économique
français pour 18 milliards d'euros
est-ce que vous croyez sérieusement
monsieur le sénateur que toutes les
entreprises françaises ont besoin que 18
milliards d'euros d'argent public du
contribuable soit mise à contribution
pour les soutenir face à la crise de
l'électricité je pense que c'est tout
simplement un gigantesque gaspillage
d'argent public vous dites toujours que
nous en faisons trop pour les
entreprises et bien là je peux vous dire
que ce serait infiniment trop et tout
simplement du gaspillage d'argent public
nous allons nous allons prendre le
contrôle à 100% d'EDF demandez à EDF de
remettre en état les réacteurs
nucléaires qui doit l'être s'engager
totalement sur la construction de six
nouveaux EPR maintenir l'unité du groupe
EDF voilà la feuille de route qui est
fixée au nouveau président EDF quant à
la réforme du marché européen je vous
rejoins nous livrons cette bataille avec
la première ministre nous la gagnerons
pour que nos compatriotes payent
l'énergie nucléaire au prix de
l'électricité du nucléaire
monsieur
montogeth vous avez pas vraiment répondu
à la question relativement à
l'organisation de l'entreprise EDF ça
fait des mois que les ministres en
charge nous berce de parole l'initiantes
et que rien ne se profile comme mesure
intense peu efficace en France et en
Europe ce qui est ici en question c'est
la capacité du président de la
République et de votre gouvernement a
peser sur la réforme du marché de
l'électricité dans l'Union européenne
l'entreprise nationale EDF doit être au
cœur de la reconquête de la souveraineté
économique française et le groupe
socialiste du Sénat soutiendra le texte
de Philippe Brun
la parole
et cette fois-ci pour Madame Guylaine
Portel pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et sociale européen vous
avez la parole monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'Ital notamment chargé de la
vie associative
le projet de réforme des retraites dont
les discussions ont commencé à
l'Assemblée nationale inquiète aussi les
élus locaux et le monde associatif
parce que cela ne relève pas de votre
délégation je ne vous interrogerai pas
sur l'augmentation de la cotisation de
la Caisse nationale de retraite des
agents des collectivités locales que
vous souhaitez imposer aux employeurs
territoriaux à compter de 2024 et à
laquelle il s'oppose fermement
en revanche parmi les sujets qui
semblent être des angles de mort de
votre réforme il y a les effets que peut
avoir le recul proposé de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite sur l'engagement
politique et associatif local
en effet la retraite est souvent
l'occasion pour bon nombre de personnes
de franchir le pas d'une candidature à
l'élection municipale de son village ou
d'être administrateur et bénévole d'une
association culturelle sportive ou
sociale
selon une étude réalisée notamment par
la Carsat des Hauts de France 35% des
retraités engagés dans une association
n'était pas engagée avant leur départ en
retraite du côté de l'engagement
politique à la suite des élections
municipales de 2020 le nombre de maires
de plus de 60 ans 60 ans pardon a
atteint 55%
. en somme être retraité c'est un
dossier un rôle non négligeable dans la
cohésion sociale de notre pays qui plus
est lorsqu'on sait que ce sont les
profils les plus assidus dans leur
mission bénévole et fonction électives
du fait de leur disponibilité
mais nous devons malgré tout considérer
que cette situation est fragile car les
difficultés de renouvellement des
équipes sont déjà perceptibles en raison
de statut de l'élu local et de droit des
bénévoles inadaptés à notre époque
ainsi avez-vous anticipé et évalué les
impacts de votre réforme sur la
dynamique de l'engagement je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Olivier Véran ministre délégué chargé du
renouveau démocratique qui porte parole
du gouvernement merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Guylaine
Portel merci pour votre pour votre
question vous m'interrogez sur la prise
en compte du bénévolat dans la réforme
des retraites notamment et il est vrai
que l'engagement associatif constitue
une des pierres angulaire de la cohésion
de notre société l'engagement bénévole
notamment pour les responsables
d'associations ça prend du temps et de
l'énergie alors oui réfléchissons à la
manière de valoriser cette engagement et
de l'encourager la prise en compte pour
la les cotisations retraite pose
toutefois un certain nombre de questions
la première sur les bénéfices sur les
bénévoles à valoriser puisque la plupart
d'entre eux acquièrent déjà des droits à
retraite au titre de leur activité
principale ensuite sur le financement de
ses droits puisque le financement de
trimestre de retraite peut devenir
rapidement une charge difficilement
assumable pour les associations qui sont
concernées plus généralement il nous
appartient de veiller au caractère
contributif et à l'é de notre système de
retraite c'est la raison pour laquelle
les modalités d'acquisition de droit à
la retraite pour les bénévoles doit
faire l'objet effectivement d'une
analyse approfondie pour en assurer la
bonne mise en oeuvre nous espérons que
les débats actuellement à l'Assemblée
nationale permettront d'aborder ce sujet
avec les différents amendements qui sont
déposés à l'article 7 je pense en
particulier un amendement du groupe
Renaissance qui vise à évaluer
l'opportunité d'accorder des droits
supplémentaires à la retraite aux
responsables associatifs par ailleurs
vous n'avez pas posé la question mais
vous avez abordé le sujet du financement
de la réforme par les collectivités
territoriales et effectivement le régime
de retraite des fonctionnaires
hospitaliers territoriaux la CNRACL un
déficit qui est important projeté de
l'ordre de 8 milliards d'euros avant
réforme en 2030 c'est avant tout le
résultat d'une question démographique ce
que vous savez et c'est pourquoi le
projet de réforme des retraites prévoit
que les employeurs contribueront
légèrement davantage leur taux de
cotisation passant de 30,65 à
31,65% l'année suivante est une hausse
d'un point ça reste largement inf au
taux de cotisations implicite dans la
fonction publique d'État de l'ordre de
74% mais je vous confirme que l'État
sera aux côtés des collectivités pour
les accompagner et assurer une
compensation madame la Première ministre
a répondu par écrit à David Lisnard le
président de l'AMF pour préciser ce
point et annoncer qu'une constatation
aurait lieu avec les ministres concernés
je vous remercie merci
la parole est maintenant de notre
collègue Daniel Breuillet pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à Madame panier
rue Nachet ministre de la transition
énergétique madame la ministre pour le
nucléaire rien n'est donc impossible le
Pr Flamanville est un échec opérationnel
et économique selon la Cour des comptes
mais qu'importe le président engage la
France pour six nouveaux EPR le débat
public sur les EPR 2 est en cours la
concertation sur le mix énergétique n'a
pas encore eu lieu comme disait mon
collègue Daniel salmon ici même mais
qu'importe on vote une loi
d'accélération du nucléaire qui change
le mix énergétique avant d'en débattre
au fond et lundi dernier nouveau fait du
prince les salariés de l'Institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
l'IRSN ont appris le démantèlement de
leur institution pourtant reconnu
internationalement la surprise fut
totale créant sidération et inquiétude
pour ces 1700 salariés l'IRSN n'a jamais
failli dans ses missions au bénéfice de
la sûreté l'organisation dual choisit
avec la distinction entre d'un côté
l'indépendance de l'expertise et de la
recherche via l'IRSN et de l'autre le
contrôle et la décision via l'ASN c'est
avéré efficace et garante de la sûreté
c'est un garde-fou institutionnel
construit après la catastrophe de
Tchernobyl et dont l'utilité a été
prouvé après Fukushima alors que vous
relancez un programme nucléaire
d'ampleur il nous paraît essentiel de ne
pas casser une organisation qui a fait
la preuve de son efficacité pourquoi
voulez-vous démanteler l'IRSN est-ce une
demande de l'exploitant dès lors que les
exigences de sûreté de l'URSS qui ne
répondent je le rappelle qu'au seul
considérations scientifique lui
apparaissent trop élevé madame la
ministre vous n'avez jamais évoqué cette
hypothèse lors de nos débats récents sur
l'accélération du nucléaire quel
reproche formez-vous à l'encontre de
l'IRSN et de ses agents alors que toutes
les évaluations sont positives ou sont
les impacts d'une telle mesure pourquoi
éloigner la représentation nationale de
ces choix essentiels pour accélérer le
nucléaire vous n'avez pas à affaiblir
les exigences de sûreté
[Applaudissements]
à la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche madame
retaillou
monsieur le sénateur broy
é qui est retenu au Parlement européen
justement pour des fentes le nucléaire
bas carbone donc je prends la parole
moi-même alors vous le savez le
gouvernement mène aujourd'hui une
politique énergétique qui vise à la fois
à sécuriser nos approvisionnements que
énergétique mais aussi à garantir des
prix compétitifs pour le pouvoir d'achat
des Français et aussi tout cela en
participant également à la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique alors pour
cela effectivement nous devons relever
de grands défis et le nucléaire en est
un outil premièrement vous l'avez dit en
réunissant les conditions de
prolongation du parc nucléaire existant
aussi en se mettant en ordre de bataille
pour maîtriser tous les coups et vous
l'avez dit aussi les délais de
construction des nouveaux EPR 2 et puis
et je voudrais insister aussi sur la
notion d'accélération et de coordination
de la recherche pour le développement en
particulier des petits réacteur
modulaire français donc vous le voyez
cette relance du nucléaire c'est
effectivement liée à beaucoup d'enjeux
de souveraineté de compétitivité
d'attractivité à long terme mais aussi
de sûreté nucléaires cette sûreté
nucléaire elle est évidemment
complètement nécessaire pour avoir la
confiance des citoyens dans le nucléaire
et vous l'avez dit en poursuivant la
concertation des acteurs locaux et en
développant l'expertise de la filière en
particulier sur le volet de la recherche
mais aussi des entreprises j'en viens
donc sur le fait que depuis toujours il
y a eu la volonté d'assurer cette
indépendance de la sûreté nucléaire et
de maintenir une recherche d'excellence
dans ce domaine
l'IRSN est un établissement public qui a
les deux volets recherche et sur tes
nucléaires et donc aujourd'hui il s'agit
de mieux de plus articulé cette
expertise d'un côté de sûreté nucléaire
de l'URSS avec celui de la SN et de
l'autre le volet de la recherche avec
celui de du CEA sur ce modèle qui existe
dans de nombreuses autres pays et qui
aussi font sa preuve c'est une étude à
regarder aujourd'hui alors ce type de
réorganisation vous l'avez dit doit être
fait avec soins et c'est pour ça qu'on a
demandé aux dirigeants de l'IRSN la SN
et du CEA de nous proposer des scénarios
merci beaucoup
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Joël guerriot
il avait plus peur
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le 11 février dernier à 13h
sans le moindre préavis des contrôleurs
aériens à Orly se sont mis en grève les
compagnies aériennes ont été
immédiatement contraintes de réduire
leur programme à un vol sur deux 25
arrivées et 22 départs ont ainsi été
annulé
comment peut-on justifier aujourd'hui
que les contrôleurs aériens ne soient
pas soumis au même règle du droit de
grève que tout autre profession dans le
domaine aérien de tels blocages causent
de graves préjudice un parcours du
combattant commence pour les usagers
dans une pagaille monstre les passagers
doivent trouver des alternatives des
solutions pour répondre à l'urgence et
aussi pour se faire rembourser leurs
billets il y a un peu plus de 4 ans dans
cette hémicycle je présentais une
proposition de loi visant à rendre
obligatoire la déclaration d'un préavis
de grève des contrôleurs aériens entre
2010 et 2016 12 milliards d'euros
avaient été perdus à cause de ces
blocages la France était à l'origine de
97% des perturbations aériennes au sein
de l'Union européenne
l'impact environnemental doit être aussi
pris en considération les compagnies
étrangères contournent le ciel français
ça représente environ 6 millions de
kilomètres additionnels et autant de
pollution
il convient d'assurer la continuité du
service public en soumettant le droit de
grève des contrôleurs aériens un système
de notification préalable de 48 heures
comme c'est d'ailleurs le cas pour
toutes les autres professions du monde
aérien monsieur le ministre n'est-il pas
temps de faire bouger les lignes afin
d'éviter ce genre de situation que vous
avez vous-même qualifié d'irrespectueuse
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes délégués changer les
transports monsieur Clément bonne vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur guerriot
vous avez raison je reprendrai les
termes exactes que j'ai employé lundi
après cette grève surprise elle a été
irrespectueuse bien sûr à l'égard des
usagers elle a été irresponsable j'ai
toujours défendu y compris dans ces
moments de tension le dialogue social le
respect des organisations syndicales en
l'occurrence il s'était agit d'un
contournement des appels qui avaient été
portés ou qui n'avaient pas été portés
par certaines organisations syndicales
et de quelques individus qui ont très
gravement pénalisé de manière inattendue
de manière surprise et de manière
irresponsable je le redis les départs de
plusieurs milliers de passagers à
l'aéroport d'Orly dans plusieurs
aéroports français vous le savez le
secteur aérien des règles particulières
il est soumis au service minimum en
effet mais pour être activé le service
minimum nécessite un peu de
prévisibilité et c'est
traditionnellement dans notre contrôle
aérien en France une forme de pacte
social qui permet que la prévisibilité
soit donnée par les organisations
syndicales à la direction générale de
l'aviation civile pour activer dans les
aéroports qui sont soumis dont
évidemment les grandes plateformes
parisiennes ce service minimum je note
d'ailleurs que dans les journées de
mobilisation des dernières semaines cela
a fonctionné faut-il repenser un certain
nombre de règles ou de pratique au vu de
ce comportement inattendu et
inacceptable je le crois j'ai dès lundi
demandé à Direction générale de
l'aviation civile de mener une
négociation interne d'abord avec les
organisations syndicales pour regarder
ce qui pouvait être fait pour mieux
prévoir les choses et activer s'il le
faut comme nous le ferons à nouveau pour
demain le service minimum pour préserver
au maximum les vols et les usagers
faut-il regarder d'autres options nous y
sommes ouverts sous l'autorité de la
première ministre nous aurons ces
discussions dans les prochaines semaines
la loi n'a pas prévu même si vous l'avez
rappelé il y a déjà eu un certain nombre
de débats sur ce sujet n'a pas prévu en
complément du service minimum une
obligation de déclaration préalable
comme cela existe dans les transports
terrestres par exemple nous regardons
les choses sans tabou d'abord la
négociation interne parce que je crois
ce dialogue social et que ce pacte a
jusqu'à présent fonctionner et puis nous
regarderons avec le Parlement le cas
échéance l'autorité de la première mise
l'ensemble des pistes complémentaires
dont celle que vous avez évoqué dans les
prochaines semaines et dans les
prochains mois si cela est nécessaire
merci beaucoup
moi je pense qu'il est très important
que le cadre juridique français protège
les passagers et à ce titre je voudrais
rappeler qu'il y a une recommandation
européenne qui est de porter le préavis
syndical à 21 jours et individuel à 72
heures donc nous en sommes loin je pense
que nous avons une marge de progrès pour
éviter ce que nous faisons subir à nos
passagers merci
la parole est au président Roger
carotschi pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la ministre la France dispose
d'une autorité de régulation des médias
arcoms
sur son site
affirme qu'elle travaille naturellement
avec le Parlement puisque le Parlement
désigne 6 de ces 9 membres mais qu'elle
est totalement indépendante du
gouvernement alors madame la ministre
j'aimerais devant la représentation
nationale que vous nous rappeliez votre
définition personnelle de l'expression
totalement indépendante du gouvernement
pour vous répondre à la parole comme
madame la ministre de la Culture
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur Elvis
Président carochi vous êtes un grand
spécialiste de l'audiovisuel nous avons
eu plusieurs réunions à ce sujet
et je pense aussi vous reprenez toutes
mes interviews toutes mes déclarations
publiques depuis mai dernier où j'ai été
nommé ministre vous pourrez voir qu'à
aucun moment
à aucun moment je n'ai commenté une
décision de l'arcom à aucun moment je
n'ai fait d'appréciation sur le travail
de l'arcom autorité bien évidemment
strictement absolument indépendante je
me borne à rappeler le cadre de la loi
les obligations les droits et les
devoirs que la loi de 86 prévoit pour
les chaînes qui ont des fréquences
gratuites les chaînes de la TNT je ne
fais rien d'autre que rappeler le cadre
de la loi est-ce qu'une ministre n'a pas
le droit de rappeler la loi
est-ce qu'une ministre n'a pas le droit
de faire état de décision qui sont
publiques de l'art comme j'en fais juste
état je ne commente pas j'en fais état
je n'ai pas le droit qu'est-ce qui vous
choque et qu'est-ce qui fait peur où
sont les menaces est-ce que c'est
rappeler le cadre de la loi fait peur
j'ai envie de poser la question à ceux
qui se sentent menacés qu'est-ce qui
vous fait peur merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le président carochi
[Applaudissements]
je vous rassure
reste ton calme je vous rassure madame
la ministre pas grand chose qui me fait
peur mais je ne bois je ne vous reproche
absolument pas de faire des constats ou
des commentaires sur les chaînes c'est
parfaitement votre droit comme c'est le
mien
et j'en fais peu dommage mais en
revanche quand vous dites madame la
ministre
éventuellement je dis pas que vous
affirmez en 2025
l'art comme pourrait retirer l'agrément
je suis désolé de vous dire retirer
quand vous dites que l'arcome pourrait
retirer si cela continue l'agrément aux
chaînes en question vous interférez avec
les décisions de l'arcom
vous n'avez pas je suis désolé madame la
ministre vous pouvez commenter autant
que vous voulez tout ce que vous voulez
vous n'avez pas à dire ce que l'art
comme pourrait faire en 2025 parce qu'à
partir de là c'est interférer sur
l'indépendance de la com
et moi Madame les ministres je serai
beaucoup plus intéressé par vous
entendre sur cette fameuse réforme de
l'audiovisuel public que nous attendons
depuis cinq ans je serais beaucoup plus
grande sur la manière dont on va
financer l'audiovisuel public puisque
depuis que vous avez supprimé la
redevance audiovisuelle nous sommes dans
le nom dit et l'intérimaire alors madame
la ministre remplissez pleinement vos
fonctions personne ne vous en empêche et
laissez-la comme faire son travail
[Applaudissements]
la parole la parole est à notre collègue
Amel gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste il avait la parole monsieur
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres de la ville et du logement le
premier février dernier la Fondation
Abbé Pierre publié son 28e rapport sur
l'état du mal logement en France le
constat est accablant 330 000 personnes
sans logement sur notre territoire des
milliers d'adultes et d'enfants
refusaient chaque soir par le 115 pour
un hébergement d'urgence près de 4
millions de Français mal logés une
situation indigne dans notre pays où
force est de constater que les fractures
ne cessent de s'aggraver en cause des
évolutions conjoncturelles la crise
sanitaire avait déjà fragilisé les plus
précaires l'inflation les a ensuite
atteint de plein fouet aujourd'hui les
dépenses énergétiques deviennent
insoutenables pour de nombreux ménages
modestes cette situation s'explique
également pour des raisons structurelles
le prix Les prix à l'achat et à la
location n'ont cessé de grimper depuis
30 ans et les forts publics pour le
logement en France n'a cessé de chuter
depuis 2010 on le sait le logement et le
premier sujet de préoccupation des
Français mais il devient également une
source aggramante d'exclusion et
d'inégalités à titre d'exemple la
situation des maires de famille
monoparentales 40% des femmes avec un
enfant vivent dans de mauvaises
conditions de logements contre 20% pour
la moyenne de la population vous allez
probablement me dire monsieur le
ministre que vous n'êtes pas responsable
de l'état du mal logement en France qui
perdure depuis trop d'années mais vous
êtes aujourd'hui responsable du
changement de braquet du tournoi à
prendre pour permettre à tous les
Français de se loger dignement monsieur
le ministre allez-vous enfin relancer la
construction de logements neufs
particulièrement de logements sociaux
allez vous renouer avec l'objectif de
500 000 logements neufs par an je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est communiste délégués en charge de la
ville et du Logement Monsieur Olivier
Klein vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice yacker oui vous avez raison le
logement est une priorité pour bien
nombreux de nos concitoyens puisque
c'est une recherche importante et il
concourt au bien-être mais vous avez
aussi raison le gouvernement fait un
effort sans précédent pour lutter contre
le sans-abrisme cette question est très
prise en compte depuis le premier
quinquennat le plan logement d'abord un
qui a été lancé par le Président de la
République dès 2017 a permis à plus de
000 personnes de sortir de la rue et
avoir un toit mais dans le même temps la
situation sociale économique la
situation migratoire fait qu'il y a
toujours de nombreuses personnes dans
l'hébergement d'urgence et hier soir
encore ces 200000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence qui était ouverte dans ce pays
et là encore c'est un chiffre qui
n'avait jamais été atteint en 2017 on
avait 140000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence vous le savez une partie
importante des personnes personnes qui
sont dans l'hébergement d'urgence sont
des personnes qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui éligibles au logement social
la situation de l’hébergement d'urgence
n'est pas liée à une reprise des
expulsions bien au contraire notre
effort quotidien et celui de refuser les
expulsions locatives les prévenir et là
aussi c'était un des axes forts du
premier plan logement d'abord le
deuxième plan logement d'abord que le
gouvernement avec la première ministre
va lancer dans les jours qui viennent
aura un objectif de faire au moins aussi
bien que ces 450 000 personnes mises à
l'abri notamment les femmes sur
lesquelles il y a un travail spécifique
il y a les femmes victimes de violence
il y a 10 000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence ouvert pour les femmes
victimes de violence c'est la première
ministre a annoncé mille places de plus
pardon sur 2023 et sur le logement vous
le savez le président de la République
et la première ministre ont décidé de
mettre en place un Conseil national de
leur redécondation spécifique sur le
logement nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble des acteurs du logement pour
construire plus là on a le plus de
besoin et je vous invite puisque vous
êtes tous des élus locaux apportés avec
moi le bâton de pèlerin pour que les
élus et envie de construire plus la rue
n'a plus le besoin merci
Madame Joker quelques secondes
et bien
pas rassuré nous savons ce qu'il y a à
faire donc c'est le moment de passer aux
actes véritablement et juste le logement
ce n'est pas qu'une question technique
c'est une question d'homme et d'humain
et il s'agit de la place de chacun dans
la société ça c'est important de le
rappeler merci merci la parole
est à notre collègue Jérôme bachel pour
le groupe les républicain
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la France a cette avantage
d'être champion champion d'Europe dans
les déficits jumeaux les défis du mot
c'est à la fois le déficit budgétaire et
le déficit commercial et là pour que la
gemilité soit complète le déficit
budgétaire et le déficit commercial sont
équivalents 160 milliards à peu près
pour chacun je vous félicite pour cet
effort simplement
plusieurs économistes commencent à
s'inquiéter de la fête et ils ont raison
Rex et code par exemple nous dit entre
2019 et 2022 la France a perdu des parts
de marché et c'est un dégradé son sol
extérieur dans quasiment tous les
secteurs industriels entre 2019 et 2022
la France perd du terrain par rapport
aux autres grands pays de la zone euro
entre 2019 et 2022 la perte des parts de
marché touche quasiment tous les
secteurs des biens à exportation compte
tenu de cette
constat que comptez-vous faire pour
changer de direction
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité du procès de
l'étranger monsieur belge
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
d'abord oui vous avez raison le déficit
de la balance des biens à doubler
l'année dernière ce doublement est dû
quasi exclusivement à la facture
énergétique si quasi exclusivement à la
facture énergétique c'est tout à fait le
cas puisque vous le savez le parc
nucléaire a été presque à l'arrêt du
fait des deux années de maintenance que
nous avons dû rattraper du fait de la
pandémie et les prix des énergies
notamment le pétrole et le gaz ont plus
que doublé sur les marchés ce déficit
conjoncturel va s'effacer naturellement
il n'empêche qu'il y a un déficit
structurel j'y reviendrai mais si la
balance des biens a effectivement un
déficit record la balance des services
elle a un excédent record plus de 50
milliards d'euros et la balance des
revenus également un excédent record à
plus de 31 milliards d'euros or le
déficit commercial ce n'est pas que la
balance des biens c'est également la
balance des services et la balance des
revenus donc les chiffres présente
évidemment bien moindre que ceux que
vous annoncez sur le déficit commercial
ils sont de l'ordre de 50 milliards
d'euros comment comptons-nous agir pour
pour réduire le déficit de la balance
des biens et bien il y a deux voix le
premier évidemment c'est la
réindustrialisation du pays qui a depuis
deux ans nous avons désormais plus
d'usines qui ouvrent que d'usine qui
ferme ce sont des cas très concrets et
semi-conducteurs à Crolles c'est le
paracétamol dans l'Isère c'est le
lithium également dans le Bas-Rhin et
dans l'Allier il y a évidemment il faut
du temps pour réimplanter les usines
mais en tout cas la réindustrialisation
est en cours et la deuxième chose c'est
de porter nos PME à l'exportation nous
avons certes de bons résultats puisque
nous avons désormais 144
000 entreprises qui sont à l'export
c'est 20 000 de plus qu'il y a quelques
années mais il faut encore davantage
porter nos entreprises à l'export c'est
le travail de la team France Export et
des mesures que ce gouvernement prendra
dans les prochains mois merci
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi j'ai juste un plan banlieue
vos chiffres la dégradation c'est 60%
pour l'énergie et 40% le reste donc
c'est
vos chiffres je n'y peux rien CCA qui
est sorti donc une fois que quand on a
dit ça qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
depuis de nombreuses années parce que
moi ça fait des années qu'on nous entend
dire que vous avez réindustrialisé et
bien nous au Sénat nous faisons des
propositions pas plus tard que ce matin
il y a une très bonne PPL trans
partisane menée notamment par mon
collègue le rend Duplomb qui vous
propose des choses claires c'est pour
favoriser la compétitivité de la ferme
France et bien il faut désormais arrêter
de mettre de la norme partout sur les
entreprises et la changer tout le temps
par idéologie c'est ce que vous venez de
faire en nombreuses années sur le
nucléaire qui nous a valu effectivement
ce déficit dont vous parlez il faut
arrêter par idéologie de normer aussi
sans arrêt notre agriculture
d'un coup les néocodinoïdes un coup non
il faut essayer d'avoir de la constance
il faut aussi détaxer et avoir une
politique fiscale merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue s'abuse
vague pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain vous avez la
parole merci
ma question de s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre la mobilisation de
samedi dernier contre votre injuste et
inutile réforme des retraites fut une
grande réussite elle a permis à de
nombreux Français de dire pacifiquement
sereinement et avec détermination leur
opposition résolue cette mobilisation a
d'ailleurs été très forte dans les
villes moyennes comme par exemple lance
Boulogne Boulogne ou
saint-paul-sur-ternoise dans le
Pas-de-Calais et quand on tombe dans les
dans les cortèges auprès de population
dont c'est parfois la première
mobilisation on parle de du prix madame
la Première ministre avec comme
illustration la promesse que vous avez
faite pendant des semaines bien que vous
vous en défendiez aujourd'hui d'un
minimum de pension de retraite à 1200
euros les Français ont compris votre
opération d'illusionniste il n'y aura
pas de pension à 1200 euros sauf pour
une très faible minorité de personnes du
prix également sur la situation des
femmes qui sont les principales victimes
de votre réforme tout comme les
catégories populaires ayant commencé à
travailler tôt
votre gouvernement est décidément
toujours doux avec les puissants et dur
avec les plus fragiles le président de
la République le Gouvernement est sa
majorité de circonstances sont élastes
totalement sourds au mouvement social
sans précédent qui traverse notre pays
face au syndicat le gouvernement agité
le spectre des blocages à la veille des
vacances pour tenter de retourner
l'opinion mais ces balais bien le
président de la République le
Gouvernement et sa majorité qui bloque
le pays quel serait les conséquences si
votre néfaste projet suivait son cours
sans tenir compte de son rejet très
majoritaire dans le pays et quand
allez-vous enfin prendre la seule et
unique décision susceptible d'apaiser le
pays le retrait de votre projet de
réforme et l'ouverture de véritables
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux merci
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes délégués en short du
renouveau démocratique Monsieur Olivier
Véran merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice merci pour votre
question à ces général finalement sur la
réforme des retraites par laquelle on
s'empoing la contestation légitime de
votre camp face à une réforme qui vise à
équilibrer dans la durée un système par
répartition en demandant c'est vrai un
effort aux français via une augmentation
progressive de la durée de travail tout
au long de la carrière madame la
sénatrice
on peut dire ce qu'on veut de la réforme
vous êtes libre de le faire et vous
l'avez fait ouais mais c'est la triste
il y a des mesures de justice et de
progrès dans cette réforme comme il y en
a eu comme il n'y en avait pas eu dans
les réformes des retraites précédentes
parmi lesquels cette mesure sur le
minimum retraite qui va permettre à un
virgule 8 millions de retraités actuels
d'avoir une majoration de leur pension
de retraite souvent des petites
retraites nous pourrions nous en réjouir
et qui permettra après de 200 000
nouveaux retraités chaque année de
partir aussi avec un peu plus d'argent
ça sera 35 ans 60 70 ou 100 euros par
mois de plus en fonction de la durée de
cotisation et en fonction du niveau de
revenus tout au long de la carrière ce
que la première ministre avait déjà
annoncé lors de sa conférence de presse
inaugurale un massénatrice hier
l'Assemblée nationale légitime
évidemment dans son exercice a décidé de
rejeter à la majorité l'article 2 du
projet de loi c'est un article qui
visait à mettre en place et qui vise à
mettre en place un index senior vous
aurez en débattre prochainement au Sénat
c'est un article qui vise à faire
régresser les inégalités et les us et
les injustices qui voient de seniors
quitter leur emploi
contraint et forcé par leurs employeurs
parce qu'ils sont justement seigneurs
alors qu'ils ont énormément apporté à
l'entreprise à notre pays non mais c'est
le régime je vous dis ça parce que
pendant des semaines on a entendu des
rangs de vos collègues des rangs de la
nupesse à l'Assemblée nationale nous
dire qu'il fallait en faire davantage
pour l'emploi des seniors et le moment
venu au moment de voter pour un
dispositif qui peut-être n'est pas
parfait à leurs yeux mais qui améliore
considérablement l'emploi des signaux
dans notre pays ont décidé de s'y
opposer j'espère madame la sédatrice que
vous aurez l'occasion bientôt de voter
en faveur de cette mesure pour
revaloriser les petites retraites pour
les Français et vous serez appuyé cette
fois-ci sur le bouton favorable je vous
remercie
au-delà de la posture et des éléments de
langage que vous nous servez et que vous
nous recevez il y a les chiffres il y a
les faits et vous les connaissez
parfaitement le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain se restera
très mobilisé contre cette réforme avec
responsabilité et dans le respect du
débat mesdames et messieurs les
ministres écoutez les Français et
écouter les élus
la parole est à notre collègue Jean
Raymond Hugonnet pour le groupe
République
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires et elle a trait à la
remise en cause des chantiers de
renaturation des cours d'eau le décret
du 30 juin 2020 est très largement
simplifié les procédures préalables à
l'engagement de ce type de travaux en
soumettant ceci non plus à autorisation
mais à déclaration cela permet notamment
au syndicat mixtes chargés d'exercer la
compétence gemapi de mettre en œuvre de
nombreux chantiers de renaturation des
cours d'eau en redonnant un
fonctionnement naturel au cours d'eau en
restant des continuités écologiques en
améliorant la richesse et la variété des
espèces et des habitats en renforçant la
capacité de rétention des crues et la
réduction des inondations
or un arrêt du Conseil d'État du 31
octobre 2022 a annulé l'article du
décret du 30 juin 2020 qui simplifiait
grandement les procédures préalables aux
travaux de renaturation aujourd'hui les
présidents de syndicats demandent non
pas le rétablissement à l'identique du
texte invalidé par le Conseil d'État
mais il souhaite que les opérations de
renaturation n'aggravant pas le risque
d'inondation n'impactant pas les moulins
ne représentant pas de danger pour la
sécurité publique et n'ayant aucune
incidence dans le domaine de la
production d'énergie il souhaite tout
simplement que ces opérations demeurent
soumises au régime de la déclaration
j'ajoute qu'il est essentiel pour les
collectivités de pouvoir bénéficier des
financements favorables mis en place par
les agences de l'eau pour des projets
très largement
publicités pardon par les élus les
populations et des associations de
défense de l'environnement en l'état le
maintien d'un tel arrêt et la
suppression du système déclaratif fera
de 2023 une année blanche en matière de
travaux de Ren alors même que leur
financement est assuré et que de
nombreuses entreprises de travaux
publics attendent le lancement de ces
opérations alors Monsieur le Ministre
qu'entendez-vous faire pour que le bon
sens l'emporte
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la transition écologique
de la cohésion des territoires Monsieur
Merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Hugonnet
je vais faire très exactement ce que
vous me suggérez le gouvernement va
prendre un nouveau décret
qui finalement
est l'énumération de ce que vous venez
de dire qui tient compte des quelques
angles morts que le Conseil d'État
pointe comme étant un risque après son
arrêt d'annulation qui a été obtenu à
l'issue d'une attaque par l'association
des Amis des moulins pour que nous
gardions un système simplifié
d'autorisation pour ces travaux les 8
présidents de syndicat mix de votre
département viennent de m'écrire votre
question arrive j'allais dire au moment
où je prends connaissance de leur
courrier les consignes ont été passées
mi mars pas dans trois mois le Conseil
national de l'eau sera saisi de cette
nouvelle rédaction qui est en cours qui
tient compte des remarques du Conseil
d'État mais qui tient compte du bon sens
que vous êtes en train de décrire on
sait que les élus en particulier ceux
qui ont la responsabilité de gemapi
c'est pas qu'ils veulent pas ils sont
convaincus qu'il faut faire il y a des
financements qui existent et on se
retrouve avec des procédures qui ont
s'ajoutant aux procédures finissent par
compliquer la vie de tout le monde quand
il y a des solutions de bon sens
c'était l'objet de ce décret du 30 juin
2020 tout l'enjeu c'est de conserver
cette philosophie de faire en fonction
de ce qui nous remonte du terrain dans
un contexte et c'est là-dessus que je
veux terminer ou nous avons un enjeu de
renaturation parce que l'état global de
nos milieux aquatiques n'est pas bon et
au moment où la Commission européenne
prépare un texte sur la restauration des
milieux aquatiques de manière générale
notre pays en ayant trouvé une solution
doit faire en sorte de la mettre en
oeuvre en conservant cette philosophie
donc vous serez entendu et dans quelques
jours les présidents des syndicats
mixtes qui gèrent cette compétence
auront la satisfaction de voir que dans
la continuité de votre question c'est
exactement ce que nous allons faire
si José monsieur le ministre je dirais
que je bois vos paroles un lendemain de
Saint-Valentin merci d'écouter le Sénat
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
folio pour le groupe de l'Union
européenne
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des Armées il y a
dix jours j'étais au cœur du Dombas et
eu le privilège d'avoir un contact
direct avec des combats des combattants
Ukrainiens revenant du front ou plutôt
des tranchées
c'est Verdun au 21e siècle là-bas froid
Bou puanteur rat tire d'artillerie
continue et ses vagues répétées de chair
à canon russe qu'il faut sans cesse
contenir puis repousser tel est leur
enfer quotidienne et leur seul
préoccupation est de survivre pour cela
ils ont plus que jamais et urgemment
besoin de nous de notre technologie de
nos armes dont le canon César que nous
avons vu en action et qu'il loue pour
son allonge sa précision et sa mobilité
monsieur le ministre allons-nous enfin
accélérer la tendance de livraison des
obus et des pièces détachées qui leur
font si terriblement défaut ainsi que
les 12 Césars supplémentaires prévus
allons-nous livrer les blindés légers
RC promis et si oui quand et combien
allons-nous leur accorder de nouveaux
radars et systèmes de défense elle est
rue ou crâne si utile pour la protection
des infrastructures et des populations
civiles quel est votre position sur
l'impérieuse fourniture d'avions de
combat
pour vous répondre
la parole de la secrétaire d'État en
charge les anciens combattants de la
mémoire madame mirales merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur Folliot
tout d'abord je voudrais excuser le
ministre des armées qui est retenu à
Bruxelles dans le cadre d'une réunion
ministérielle de l'OTAN monsieur le
sénateur je connais votre engagement sur
ces sujets et je vous suis
reconnaissante de les porter devant nous
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du soutien que
la France octobre l'Ukraine nous
examinons trois critères fondamentaux à
chaque fois que nous procédons à une
session d'armes à l'Ukraine un la
réponse aux priorités des demandes des
Ukrainiens dans une logique défensive et
dans la maîtrise du risque d'escalade de
la préservation de notre modèle de
sécurité et de défense trois
l'efficacité opérationnelle rapide des
capacités fournies avec des équipements
fonctionnels une formation adaptée des
munitions et le MCO nous répondons
rapidement aux priorités des demandes du
criniennes sur les blender de combat
l'artillerie et la défense
solaire les canons César sont une
réponse adaptée 18 canons sont déjà
livrés seront complétés rapidement par
les nouveaux canons français et danois
la France a par ailleurs donné des lr.u
avec des lots de requête de même pour la
défense solaire nous avons déjà livré
des missiles Mistral et des batteries
crâtales nous poursuivrons l'aide à la
protection du territoire ukrainien en
livrant au printemps avec les Italiens
une batterie santé monsieur le sénateur
nous poursuivons la formation d'unités
blindée avec par exemple des chars
légers à mx-10rc qui rend bien et
bientôt en Ukraine par ailleurs nous
avons créé avec le Parlement un fond
spécial de soutien de 200 millions
d'euros qui ont déjà été bien utilisés
il permet à l'Ukraine d'utiliser du
matériel directement auprès des
industriels français par exemple il va
permettre la fourniture de 12 Césars
supplémentaires et d'un radar
gm200 il vient compléter le soutien que
nous portons à travers la facilité
européenne pour la paix nous avons
collectivement engagé plus de 3,5
milliards d'euros nous ne nous
interdisons rien et d'autres sessions
pourraient être engagées et envisager
dans les temps qui viennent
monsieur folio
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre je regrette que vous
l'ayez pu répondre aux questions de très
précises que j'avais posées je dis
simplement qu'il y a une situation qui
est une situation d'urgence sur place et
que nous devons aider l'Ukraine
fortement et maintenant je crois que
c'est un élément et un enjeu essentiel
nous devons et la France doit à l'instar
d'autres pays être en première ligne en
la matière et ceci est très important je
crois que c'est notre devoir mais plus
encore de les aider maintenant et comme
il le faut c'est notre honneur
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
sotorel pour le groupe
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
préparation de la rentrée scolaire
suscite incompréhension et colère dans
nos territoires ruraux nous vous avons
déjà interrogé et nous avons bien
compris que votre matière favorite était
les mathématiques la référence au ratio
plutôt que les humanités le département
du Cantal n'échappe pas à cette règle
Juniac la bescherette sans sac 50
valmeroux hit de les ternes murain
Saint-Flour sur les victimes de
l'emmener avec cette même logique
inacceptable beaucoup d'autres suivront
cette année nous sommes en plus victime
d'un marché de dupes qui consiste à
accroître les moyens de votre ministère
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
de 6,5% malgré la baisse des effectifs
et de constater les réductions de moyens
sur nos territoires tout cela sans
concertation sans délai de prévenance
avec une méthodologie datant de la
Troisième République sans laisser le
temps aux familles aux élus de
s'organiser à ignorant les initiatives
prises sur les territoires les
investissements réalisés par les mers
alors monsieur le ministre si vous
voulez vraiment réduire nos moyens bien
qu'on augmente les vôtres ne le faites
pas au détriment des élèves et des
effectifs présents devant les lèvres
pour le Cantal par exemple c'est
seulement 670 enseignants du premier
degré sur 780 qui sont devant les lèvres
soit ratio de 85 % sans parler des
effectifs administratifs monsieur le
ministre pensez-vous améliorer ce ratio
en remettant des enseignants devant nos
élèves des classes rurales pour ne pas
envoyer un signal mortifère à nos
petites écoles qui sont la vie de nos
communes je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole auto
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse j'ai pas fait de
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur sautarell la France est
confrontée un problème de natalité qui
n'épargne pas malheureusement votre
département cette situation nous amène
en effet à procéder à des ajustements
dans la carte scolaire selon deux
principes un principe d'équité
territorial et de fait nous accompagnons
les territoires qui gagnent des élèves
en créant des postes de façon
substantielle et deuxièmement un
principe d'universalité de l'école
puisque nous devons avoir une attention
particulière c'est vrai au territoire
ruraux nous sommes dans une phase de la
première phase d'élaboration de la carte
scolaire et cette phase va aboutir à une
autre étape en juin et enfin au mois
d'août au niveau national le nombre
d'élèves par classe et de 21,7 dans
votre département monsieur le sénateur
c'est 17 élèves par classe ce qui est
tout à fait raisonnable nous tenons nos
engagements par l'engagement du
président de la République de ne fermer
aucune école en milieu rural sans
l'accord du maire et également c'est
l'objet de l'augmentation du budget de
l'Éducation nationale que vous avez
mentionné en augmentant la rémunération
des professeurs pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir pardon les postes mis au
concours il faut mieux payer les
professeurs et c'est ce que nous allons
faire dès la rentrée
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je crains que vous n'ayez pas
tout à fait répondu à ma question et et
les ratios je les connais et je ferai
pas l'affront de vous rappeler en plus
l'engagement du président de la
République était de ne plus supprimer ne
plus fermer de classe et non pas d'école
sans la vie du maire mais surtout je
voudrais mettre une touche d'humour à ce
débat un humour absurde pour montrer
l'absurdité de la situation que nous
vivons chaque jour je vous invite à lire
un texte illustratif intitulé
rationalisation de l'orchestre j'insiste
vraiment lisez le cela permet de ramener
un orchestre symphonique de 82 à huit
musiciens je suis sûr que cela vous
intéressera
la parole est à notre collègue Isabelle
briquet pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la préparation de la carte
scolaire 2023-2024 se traduit par des
suppressions importantes de postes
particulièrement dans le premier degré
comme ça a été relevé tout à l'heure
dans de nombreux départements la rentrée
sera donc une fois de plus compliqué en
Haute Vienne par exemple de nombreux
fermetures de classe et suppression de
poste sont prévues alors même que le
taux d'encadrement est inférieur à la
moyenne nationale la baisse du nombre
d'élèves accueillis ne saurait tout
justifier les laboration de la carte
scolaire ne peut être dictée par de
simples considérations comptables
monsieur le ministre l'école publique
étant bien mauvais état le constat est
cruel mais hélas sans appel dans tous
les territoires ruraux comme urbain en
région comme à Paris dans le primaire
comme dans le secondaire des classes
sans enseignant pendant plusieurs jours
trans en garderie
des enfants en situation de handicap
accueillies sans moyens supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire sans véritable possibilité
d'inclusion
un tel état des lieux justifierait à lui
seul un moratoire sur la fermeture de
classe au-delà de ce moratoire se pose
la question des moyens que nous voulons
donner à l'école publique pour assurer
l'avenir de nos enfants aussi Monsieur
le Ministre comptez-vous sortir de la
logique comptable afin de doter
l'éducation nationale des moyens
indispensables aux besoins des enfants
des enseignants et des territoires je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole Leto ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice briquet je
ne reviendrai pas sur la question
démographique sauf pour noter que dans
votre département la baisse des lèvres
sera de 400 400 élèves à la rentrée je
vous rappelle en outre que la
préparation des mesures de rentrée est
un travail qui commence très en amont et
que ce travail comporte plusieurs la
base d'échanges et de dialogue avant que
des décisions définitives soient prises
au mois de juin et au mois d'août et les
décisions définitives ne sont pas encore
prises avec les dazaines les recteurs
les inspecteurs d'académie nous sommes
encore dans cette phase de dialogue et
d'échanges nous fermons des classes
c'est vrai nous en ouvrant aussi
beaucoup je suis convaincu comme vous
que l'école est un facteur de
dynamisation des territoires et ce
travail doit être mené je vous l'accorde
entre les élus locaux et l'éducation
nationale dans 10 académies aujourd'hui
nous avons créé les territoires
éducatifs ruraux qui permettent d'unir
les forces de l'éducation nationale et
les collectivités c'est un programme
intéressant parce qu'il permet de
construire des projets qui renforcent
l'attractivité des territoires et je
souhaite justement étendre à tous les
territoires ruraux ces programmes qui
montrent déjà leur efficacité enfin
madame la sénatrice je me permets de
vous remarqué à propos des moyens de
l'école que l'augmentation de 6,5% soit
3,7 milliards d'euros c'est une
augmentation conséquente qui va nous
permettre de mieux payer les professeurs
par conséquent de pourvoir les postes
que nous mettons au concours c'est
exactement ce que vous vous n'avez pas
fait entre 2012 et 2017
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre la fin de votre
réponse est un peu facile mais l'effet
sont là promouvoir l'égalité des chances
lutter contre les fractures
territoriales émanciper et formée de
futurs citoyens telles sont les missions
de notre système éducatif monsieur le
ministre notre école va mal la méthode
doit changer vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure tout est question de choix et ce
n'est pas en supprimant des postes que
notre école publique ira mieux
la parole est à notre collègue Fabien
Genet pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur
le ma question s'adresse au ministre de
la Santé monsieur le ministre naître ou
ne plus naître à hautain tel est
désormais la question question qui
angoisse les 62000 habitants du Morvan
entre Saône-et-Loire Nièvre et Côte-d'Or
Suite à votre annonce de la fermeture de
la maternité d'Autun cette fermeture
provoque un vent de colère et de révolte
chez les équipes de soignants au combien
dévoués mais aussi chez les élus locaux
et la population devant ce qui est vécu
comme un nouveau déménagement du
territoire cette fermeture suscite
l'inquiétude des femmes enceintes
désormais contraintes de parcourir plus
d'une heure voire 1h30 de route pour se
rapprocher d'une maternité alors même
qu'une étude réalisée dans notre région
montrait combien l'augmentation de cette
distance retentit sur la santé
périnatale cette fermeture locale doit
préoccuper au niveau national car
monsieur le ministre vous avez commencé
par la justifier ainsi nous n'arrivons
plus à trouver des professionnels pour
assurer la sécurité est-ce déjà votre
seul politique après avoir fermé une
maternité sur trois en 20 ans votre
ministère va-t-il amplifier cette
concentration et fermer toutes les
maternités de niveau 1 du pays et puis
face au tollé provoqué par votre annonce
vous avez renié le mot de fermeture dans
un tweet qui disait inexact les
accouchements sont suspendus aujourd'hui
pour manque de personnel finalement
monsieur le ministre de la Santé est-ce
là votre seul ambition face aux pénuries
médicales que de demander aux femmes de
suspendre les accouchements et aux
malades de suspendre leur maladie
pour vous répondre la parole commise de
la santé Monsieur François Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Jeunet merci de me donner l'occasion de
parler de ce dossier dans le fond et
j'en suis sûr en dehors de toute
polémique
quelle est la situation actuelle les
accouchements sont suspendus à la
maternité d'otin depuis mi-décembre par
faute de personnel médical j'imagine que
comme moi vous refusez de mettre en
danger la fin de la santé des femmes par
thuriante et des enfants parce qu'elle
n'aurait pas de personnel compétent pour
les prendre en charge alors des
décisions nombreuses ont été prises la
première j'ai décidé de repousser la
date de la commission qui devait dans
quelques jours décider de l'avenir du
site pour que nous prenions un peu plus
de temps pour construire des solutions
pour répondre aux besoins de santé de la
population il est hors de question bien
entendu que les femmes du Morvan n'est
pas de solution satisfaisante au moment
de leur grossesse
pendant ce temps nous allons continuer à
travailler avec les élus avec les
professionnels avec les représentants
des patients et des patients plusieurs
pistes se dessinent déjà
particulièrement sérieuses la première
met en place sur hautain une ligne
d'intervention supplémentaire avec une
ambulance dédiée et une sage-femme en
complément du SMUR pour la prise en
charge éventuelle d'accouchement qui se
ferait en extra hospitalier ensuite nous
mettons en place un service de
péripaternité à hautain c'est à dire la
prise en charge des femmes jusqu'à
l'accouchement et tout de suite après
l'accouchement avec une antenne
d'ailleurs à Château-Chinon pour mieux
couvrir l'ensemble du Morvan de la même
façon mise en place d'un système
d'hébergement des femmes juste avant
l'accouchement sur nos principes d'hôtel
hospitaliers au plus près de plateau
technique d'accouchement et enfin la
mise en place de consultations de
pédiatrie sur le site en concertation et
en complémentarité avec le CHU de Dijon
et château
Chalon-sur-Saône pardon donc voilà les
solutions que nous travaillons j'aurai
l'occasion de venir sur place pour
présenter les solutions que nous aurons
définies ensemble bien entendu nous
mettrons le financement adéquat pour les
développer je suis de très près ce sujet
car il est emblématique de la
construction d'une réponse à l'échelle
du territoire et non plus simplement de
façon focalisée je vous remercie
monsieur je n'ai
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'entends
votre réponse vous proposez
effectivement la transformation de la
maternité en centre périnatale de
proximité comme un une très grande
nouveauté alors même que je crois que
les décrets de 1998 il y a 25 ans
prévoyait déjà cette solution et que
dans notre région ça a été tenté à
Cosne-sur-Loire et vous savez que ce
centre a dû fermer faute de personnel je
crois que les acteurs locaux attendent
des garanties réelles pour que votre bon
concept de maternité territoriale ne
soit pas seulement un slogan pour
masquer la réalité celle d'un territoire
sans maternité
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
sigoletti pour le groupe de l'Union
santé
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur luministre
de l'économie et des finances monsieur
le ministre le 1er juillet 2007 la
France ouvrait son marché de
l'électricité et du gaz à la concurrence
pour les particuliers faisant naître par
la même occasion des promesses sur une
baisse des prix sur un système plus
performant et plus lisible pour les
consommateurs 16 ans après je crois
pouvoir dire au nom de millions de
Français que le poids de l'énergie sur
le budget des ménages est aujourd'hui
extrêmement préoccupant sans surprise
différentes études montrent que le prix
d'électricité a progressé de 50% disant
et ce n'est malheureusement pas terminé
même constat alarmant pour le gaz au
final comme souvent c'est le
consommateur qui paie les frais de la
situation actuelle dont les causes sont
multiples guerres en Ukraine marché
européen de l'énergie en difficulté et
stratégie énergétique des différents
gouvernements souvent incohérentes pour
d'ici le 30 juin 2023 les tarifs
réglementés du gaz sont vous et à
disparaître obligeant des millions de
ménages à renégocier leur contrats avec
des tarifs qui vont bondir alors que la
reprise économique sa mort sans Chine et
que ce pays va fortement augmenter sa
consommation de gaz il y a fort à
craindre que son prix s'envole et que le
marché mondial s'affole dans ce contexte
il est urgent de prolonger ses tarifs
réglementés pour ne pas plonger des
millions de Français dans la précarité
énergétique monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple sans créer un
nouveau chèque allez-vous reporter la
fin des tarifs réglementés de gaz prévu
le 30 juin 2023 sachant que depuis
octobre 2021 la Commission européenne
autorise les États à prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles pour la protection des
consommateurs je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Économie des Finances et
la souverain sénateur les prix ne vont
pas bondir pour le consommateur je vous
rassurer tout de suite ça fait deux ans
deux ans que la France plus que aucun
autre État européen protège le
consommateur français contre la flambée
des prix du gaz et la flambée des prix
de l'électricité ça s'appelle le
bouclier tarifaire
tervégaz ou Pather Vegas en juillet 2023
une fois qu'effectivement le TRV aura
été supprimé il y aura la même
protection le même bouclier et le
consommateur ne paiera pas davantage
d'après un ministre indiqué le bouclier
tarifaire est maintenu jusqu'à la fin
2023 je rappelle par ailleurs que sur 12
millions de consommateurs de gaz dis
sont déjà fait le choix de sortir des
TRV ce que je sais bien que les mots
entretiennent la confusion mais autant
sur l'électricité nous sommes
producteurs donc nous pouvons réguler
plafonner le tarif de l'électricité
c'est ce que nous ont avec les terres
électricité pour les très petits
entreprises c'est ce que nous faisons
avec la reine qui permet de réduire en
moyenne de 50% la facture d'électricité
des entreprises en France là nous
pouvons le faire et nous continuerons à
le faire parce que nous sommes
producteurs d'électricité notamment de
l'électricité nucléaire mais nous ne
sommes pas producteurs de gaz donc nous
n'avons jamais n'avons pas les moyens de
plafonner de prix du gaz il y a
simplement un prix de référence qui est
fixé par la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie ce prix de référence sera
maintenu quoi qu'il arrive sur les prix
du gaz au-delà de juin 2023 et je le
redis la protection tarifaire elle elle
sera garantie par le bouclier que nous
avons mis en place
merci monsieur le ministre mais dans un
environnement de plus en plus dérégulé
le tarif réglementé de vente du gaz
reste une référence claire sur le marché
si le tarif réglementé disparaît il
manquera une référence à laquelle se
référer en cette période de trouble
merci
la parole est
notre collègue Stéphane Ravier pour la
Réunion administrative des signataires
ne figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse Madame
la Ministre de la censure de la culture
pardon dans la culture
c'est assumé prendre c'est un si
méprendre madame la ministre le 9
février dernier vous avez clairement
menacé de ne pas renouveler les
fréquences de chaîne d'information
privée depuis les studios de média
public ces propos choquants représentent
une atteinte à l'indépendance de l'arcom
chargé de réguler la communication
audiovisuelle une atteinte au plus
réalisme portée notamment par le travail
des équipes de C8 et cnews suivi par
plus de 11 millions de téléspectateurs
quotidiennement une menace faite à la
liberté d'expression au débat
démocratique madame le ministre si vos
propos portent les valeurs de la
République ce sont celles d'une
république soviétique ou d'une
république bananière dois-je vous
rappeler que nous sommes ici à Paris et
pas à Pyongyang
votre tête à la liberté d'expression au
débat démocratique est aggravé par un
deux poids de mesure car samedi encore
la chaîne publique France 2 incapable
des gars pour les élus d'opposition
accueillis en vedette un tueur en série
sans réaction de l'arcome ni de votre
part vous avez une conception une
application très sélective du rappel du
cadre de la loi C8 collectionne elle
près de 6 millions 700 000 euros
d'amende depuis 6 ans pour 10 ans le non
respect de l'idéologie dominante mais
mon a inter Man et Françoise Laborde
toutes deux anciens membres du CSA
aujourd'hui Arcom n'ont pas manqué de
dénoncer votre insupportable pression
l'essence même de leur com et devrait
être sa totale indépendance vis-à-vis du
pouvoir politique en appelant leur
commun agir vous avez déjà et vous êtes
déjà dans l'ingérence et la pression la
vérité c'est qu'en 2025 nous serons en
deux ans de l'élection présidentielle et
que vous ne supportez plus que
l'opposition puisse s'exprimer sur une
chaîne qui pourtant fait preuve elle
de véritable pluralité en invitant
toutes les opinions toutes les opinions
à s'exprimer alors madame le ministre
alors que le renouvellement des
fréquences de la TNT a lieu en 2025
plutôt que de bravades ou de
fanfaronnade auquel garantie pouvez-vous
nous apporter pour assurer le pluralisme
la liberté de l'information du débat
dans l'audiovisuel français pour vous
répondre la parole est à madame la
ministre de la Culture madame abdull
Malak
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
sénateur ravier on termine en beauté la
première fois que je vous avais entendu
prononcé mon nom vous aviez défini ma
fonction communiste de la déculture je
vois qu'on monte d'un cran je vous
remercie pour cette considération
alors
à chaque fois je rappelle le cadre de la
loi mais ce que j'entends dans ce que
vous venez de dire c'est que vous
contestez au fond les obligations qui
sont posées dans la loi de 86 vous les
contestez visiblement Vous contestez le
fait qu'il faille respecter la dignité
des personnes dans les chaînes de la TNT
qui bénéficient de fréquence gratuite
Vous contestez le fait que on ne peut
pas insulter par exemple un
parlementaire Vous contestez le fait
qu'on ne peut pas
inciter à la haine puisque l'arcom avait
en toute indépendance c'est une décision
de l'art comme
rendu cette décision qui sanctionnait
une des chaînes que vous mentionnez pour
des propos qui en gros
insulter les mineurs étrangers en les
traitant tous de violeurs d'agresseurs
et d'assassins donc vous contestez
finalement la loi si je comprends bien
vous contester le cadre de la loi alors
que je suis ici face à des législateurs
qui sont attachés à cette loi cette loi
qui est le fondement de notre démocratie
le fondement de ce qui fait le
pluralisme l'indépendance de
l'information dans notre pays et à
laquelle je suis viscéralement attachée
c'est ça la conclusion et en plus venant
de vous
je suis d'autant plus étonnée que vous
défendiez aujourd'hui la liberté de la
presse quand on sait il y a pas si
longtemps que le candidat que vous
défendiez à l'élection présidentielle
faisait huer les journalistes dans ces
meetings et certains se sont même fait
agresser à ces meetings donc on a
vraiment pas de leçon à recevoir de
votre part respectons la loi rappelons
la loi rien que la loi merci madame la
ministre
[Applaudissements]
nous avons terminé les questions
gouvernement nos prochaines questions
auront lieu le mercredi 1er mars à 15
heures
la séance va être suspendue elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
d'approvision de loi visant à sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des Français en
produits de grandes consommations la
séance est suspendue merci
[Musique]
et voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du Sénat au gouvernement
place maintenant aux réactions je suis
avec Agnès Firmin le Bodo bonjour
peut-être vous êtes à la ministre en
charge de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé on va parler
dans quelques instants de la colère des
médecins actuellement mais d'abord un
mot sur la réforme des retraites avec le
premier revers parlementaire du
gouvernement hier et la suppression de
cette mesure de l'index pour l'emploi
des seniors Emmanuel Macron le président
de la République selon le journal Le
Figaro a réagi aujourd'hui en disant que
les oppositions avaient perdu leur
boussole notamment la gauche qui est à
voté contre cette index des seniors
alors qu'elle demande des mesures pour
l'emploi des seniors vous êtes d'accord
les oppositions sont perdues peut-être
ceux qui parlent mieux de ce qui s'est
passé hier soir dans l'hémicycle c'est
la CFDT qui clairement apprenait à
travailler avec le gouvernement sur
cette index des seniors la CFDT
travaille pour cette index des seniors
parce que l'emploi des seniors est un
véritable enjeu et hier soir dans
article ce qui sont aux côtés de la CFDT
pour manifester ont voté contre allez
comprendre alors les critiques du
président de la République allez aussi
selon le journal Le Figaro en verre les
députés les républicains dont certains
sont sceptiques vis-à-vis de ce report
de là tu as 64 ans alors que la
candidatellaire il y a un an et
défendait un report de l'âge à 65 ans
est-ce que vous craignez que les LR qui
sur le papier ont signé plutôt un pacte
avec le gouvernement pour voter cette
réforme est-ce que vous craignez qu'au
final il ne la fasse capoter hier soir
il s'agissait d'un vote sur un article
le travail se continue les discussions
se continuent et se poursuivent moi je
veux croire à un moment en la
responsabilité de chacun cette réforme
elle est nécessaire nous souhaitons
conserver ce régime par répartition qui
fait qui consolide notre facteur
républicain les LR ont toujours porté
cette réforme ici au Sénat tous les ans
bien un amendement et les socialistes
avaient eux déjà augmenté le nombre
d'années cotisations à 43 donc je crois
qu'il faut savoir aussi arrêter cette
hypocrisie je crois envers les Français
entre ce comportent et ce qu'on fait
dans l'hémicycle et avoir maintenant si
les quelques députés LR du groupe llaré
l'assemblée qui sont sur le papier
réfractaire assez 64 ans rentreront dans
le rang alors madame la ministre
quelques questions justement sur la
colère des médecins ils étaient de
nouveau en grève hier pour protester
contre plein de motifs d'abord à motif
le prix de la consultation il demande
une hausse de la consultation alors
certains médecins veulent passer de 25 à
50 euros pour l'instant en face
l'assurance maladie dans les
négociations proposent seulement une
hausse d'un euro 50 est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à une hausse supplémentaire de
la consultation pour les médecins
la négociation a lieu en ce moment même
le directeur de la CNAM Thomas fatum qui
mène la consultation les recevra de
nouveau demain comme ça a été comme ça a
été annoncé une première proposition a
été faite avec une augmentation à 26
euros de la consultation le directeur de
la CNAM c'est exprimé hier en disant que
dans le cadre du gagnant-gagnant en face
d'un engagement notamment un engagement
territorial peut-être que la
consultation pourrait augmenter donc
nous sommes bien là avec une réponse à
apporter à la fois à une colère que nous
entendons des médecins mais aussi à la
fois avec une nécessité de répondre aux
besoins de nos concitoyens ils sont 6
millions à ne pas avoir de médecins
traitant nous devons répondre aussi à la
demande de nos concitoyens et donc
trouver avec les médecins des réponses à
apporter donc une hausse de la
consultation contre un effort
supplémentaire dans le travail pour pour
les médecins alors les médecins sont
également en colère sur une proposition
de loi issue de la majorité
présidentielle à l'Assemblée nationale
qui prévoit d'augmenter et d'ouvrir le
champ des compétences pour certains
professionnels de santé notamment les
professions paramédicales comme les
infirmiers en pratique avancées les
médecins estiment que ça fait ça va
créer une médecine à deux vitesses
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez tout
d'abord
face à au manque de médecins il nous
faut trouver plusieurs plusieurs
réponses la réponse c'est à la fois
augmenter le nombre de places
disponibles pour les études en médecine
c'est ce que nous avons fait nous avons
augmenté de 10 à 15% par an le monde de
place pour former des médecins mais il
nous faut aussi dégager du temps médical
dégager du temps médical ce sont les
assistants médicaux ce sont la
suppression de certains certificats
médicaux mais c'est aussi dans le camp
dans le cadre des compétences de chaque
profession pouvoir travailler de façon
coordonnée avec le médecin traitant qui
reste la pierre angulaire du système de
santé je crois qu'il faut le dire et
nous nous l'assumons vraiment avec le
ministre François Braun le médecin reste
la pierre angulaire du système de santé
mais il faut dans le cadre des
compétences de chaque professionnel
pouvoir accompagner et apporter des
réponses c'est le cadre de la loi
proposée par Stéphane iris en quelques
mots le Sénat a ajouté à la possibilité
d'une taxe sur les patients qui
honoreraient pas leur rendez-vous
médicaux vous êtes favorable je suis
favorable à ce qu'on nous trouve une
solution assez rendez vous lapin dégager
du temps médical c'est aussi respecter
et quand on prend un rendez-vous le
temps médical est précieux nous savons
tous on le Nord merci beaucoup Agnès
Firmin le Baudot d'être venu au micro de
Public Sénat merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre pour cette réaction salle des
conférences un débrief écourté
aujourd'hui puisque dans une dizaine de
minutes un petit peu moins d'une dizaine
de minutes on va rejoindre l'Assemblée
nationale pour suivre le débat sur la
réforme des retraites on va justement
s'intéresser à la façon dont le Sénat
aussi se prépare à aborder ce texte
majeur puisque vous êtes avec le patron
dessinateur socialiste il s'agit de
Patrick canard Alexandre
à l'Assemblée nationale la gauche la
nupes a rejeté l'index senior l'article
2 de cette réforme des retraites et
Emmanuel Macron selon Le Figaro ce matin
au Conseil des ministres a estimé que et
bien la gauche avait perdu sa boussole
l'opposition a perdu sa boussole car
elle défend des mesures pour l'emploi
des seniors et elle rejette cette index
sachant que l'index manifestement est
très insuffisant par rapport à
l'objectif qui est de faire comprendre
dans vos entreprises que l'intérêt de la
France c'est d'embaucher et de faire
travailler les seniors à ne pas les
licencier et d'en faire une charge pour
la société donc non cette l'index des
seniors était très largement insuffisant
par rapport à l'objectif et d'ailleurs
la nuit pêche les groupes de gauche
l'ont pas voté c'est à dire mais
d'autres y compris des LR n'ont pas voté
non plus donc ce texte est pas
consensuel et j'entends dire qu'il y
aurait une seconde délibération ce qui
est piétiné finalement le poids et le
rôle du Parlement dans notre cinquième
République c'est très dommageable et
quand le texte arrivera au Sénat début
mars est-ce que les socialistes seront
favorables à un retour de cette index
des seniors et à d'autres mesures pour
l'emploi des seniors notamment on parle
d'un bonus malus sur les entreprises oui
bonus on verra bien ce que ça veut dire
je pense que les entreprises doivent
comprendre que il y a une obligation qui
n'est pas que morale elle est aussi
économique d'embaucher les seniors donc
nous aurons des propositions
d'amendement et si ces propositions
prospère comme on dit dans notre jargon
parlementaire et bien nous pourrions
voter l'article 2 mais pas dans l'état
où il va nous de l'Assemblée je rappelle
que son taux de vraisemblance il n'y
aura pas de vote à l'assemblée du texte
et que nous aurons donc le texte de base
qui viendra de du gouvernement en direct
donc les sons du temps au temps nous
allons travailler nous préparons nos
amendements et ce que nous voulons
surtout c'est aboutir aux biens au débat
sur l'article 7 qui peut-être ne sera
pas examiné à la semaine nationale ce
qui est dommageable ça dépend du nombre
des amendements de la France insoumise
qui va ou non les retirer est-ce qu'elle
arrêtera de faire de l'obstruction
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la forme
que caprice débat à l'Assemblée
nationale notamment la violence des
propos de certains députés insoumis un
députés qui a quand même traité
d'assassin administration c'est une
forme affligeante tout le monde de la
reconnu et quel que soit les excuses il
ne fallait pas prononcer ces mots qui
sont terribles mais pour reprendre
l'expression de Boris Vallaud mon
partenaire et collègues président du
groupe socialiste à la semaine nationale
et bien nous nous pensons que un vote de
l'article 7 permettra de clarifier la
position des uns et des autres donc pour
ce qui nous concerne nous voulons qu'il
y a un débat autour de l'article 7
conclut ponctué par par un vote j'espère
que nos collègues les filles le
comprendront donc ça veut dire qu'il y
aura pas d'obstruction de la gauche au
Sénat de la gauche socialiste de la
gauche social sur l'article 7 en tant
que tel merci beaucoup Patrick Kanner
d'être venu à mon micro l'article 7 un
article phare de ce projet de loi qui
prévoit le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite 604 ans et tout
l'enjeu et de savoir si effectivement on
va arriver jusqu'à cet article d'ici
vendredi minuit tout de suite et bien on
va rejoindre Quentin calme est dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat pour revenir sur
l'un des temps forts de cette séance de
questions au gouvernement et sans
surprise il était consacré
sans conteste l'un des moments forts
puisque nous sommes on l'a bien compris
avec Alex pusard à 48 heures de la fin
de l'examen du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale on a vu les socialistes qui
ont à nouveau appelé le gouvernement à
retirer la réforme des retraites après
notamment la très forte mobilisation je
cite de la semaine dernière notamment
dans les villes moyennes écouter la
sénatrice socialiste Sabrine van eygues
elle a fustigé l’opération
d'illusionniste je cite du gouvernement
notamment sur les petites retraites
portées à 1200 euros écoutez
et quand on tombe dans les cortèges
auprès de population dont c'est parfois
la première mobilisation on parle de du
prix madame la Première ministre avec
comme illustration la promesse que vous
avez faite pendant des semaines bien que
vous vous en défendiez aujourd'hui d'un
minimum de pension de retraite à 1200
euros les Français ont compris votre
opération d'illusionniste il n'y aura
pas de pension à 1200 euros sauf pour
une très faible minorité de personnes du
prix également sur la situation des
femmes qui sont les principales victimes
de votre réforme tout comme les
catégories populaires ayant commencé à
travailler tôt votre gouvernement est
décidément toujours doux avec les
puissants et dur avec les plus fragiles
alors c'est le porte-parole du
gouvernement qui lui a répondu au nom du
gouvernement on peut dire ce que l'on
veut de cette réforme a-t-il répondu il
y a des mesures de la justice écouter la
suite
madame la sénatrice
on peut dire ce qu'on veut de la réforme
vous êtes libre de le faire et vous
l'avez fait mais c'est la triste il y a
des mesures de justice et de progrès
dans cette réforme comme il y en a eu
comme il n'y en avait pas eu dans les
réformes des retraites précédentes parmi
lesquels cette mesure sur le minimum
retraite qui va permettre à 1,8 millions
de retraités actuels d'avoir une
majoration de leur tension de retraite
souvent des petites retraites nous
pourrions nous en réjouir et qui
permettra après de 200 000 nouveaux
retraités chaque année de partir aussi
avec un peu plus d'argent ça sera 35 ans
60 70 ou 100 euros par mois de plus en
fonction de la durée de cotisation et en
fonction du niveau de revenus tout au
long de la carrière ce que la première
ministre avait déjà annoncé lors de sa
conférence de presse inaugurale et
ensuite Olivier Véran Tam d'inviter le
gouvernement à voter l'article 2 celui
sur l'index des seniors lorsque le Sénat
s'empara du texte cette même article 2
qui a été rejeté par l'Assemblée
nationale hier Tam voilà on a entendu
cet appel
au Sénat peut être un mot sur le
calendrier qui nous attend pour cet
examen de la réforme des retraites au
Sénat Quentin on l'a dit il reste 48
heures d'examen à l'Assemblée nationale
jusqu'à vendredi minuit a priori ensuite
le texte va être transmis au Sénat c'est
ce qu'on appelle la navette
parlementaire le texte sera examiné le
28 février le 1er mars en commission
puis en séance derrière moi donc à
partir du 2 du 2 mars et ce jusqu'au 12
mars qui est la date limite maximale
prévue pour l'examen de ce texte Tab
voilà 10 jours d'examens au Sénat et
bien sûr public Sénas sera là pour vous
faire vivre les débats on va conclure ce
débrief en rejoignant Alexandre Poussard
car vous êtes avec François Patriat
c'est le patron dessinateur renaissance
des seniors qui a été supprimé par le
position à l'Assemblée nationale et ce
n'est pas sûr qu'il soit rétabli dans
l'examen du texte au Sénat car quand on
écoute la droite sénatoriale bien ils ne
sont pas vraiment enclin finalement le
rétablir il préfère des mesures
incitatives pour l'emploi ingénieurs et
qu'en écoute la gauche on n'avait
Patrick Kanner à l'instant le président
du groupe socialiste pareil il s'agirait
pas forcément de le rétablir mais de
prendre des mesures pour contraindre
plus fortement les entreprises à
employer à garder en emploi des
saigneurs donc finalement François
patriar est-ce qu'il faut s'accrocher à
cette mesure d'index sur l'emploi des
seniors je crois que le secrétaire
général de la CFDT n'essayez pas trompé
quand ce matin il s'est exprimé en
disant qu'il ne comprenait plus les
parlementaires parce que lui depuis le
début des négociations qui ont porté
leurs fruits avec Olivier du socle il a
porté ce combat de l'emploi des seniors
qui ne passe pas seulement par l'index
l'index c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui est malgré tout coercitif
parce qu'il me demande au chef
d'entreprise aujourd'hui de faire la
preuve etc qu'ils doivent garder les
seniors parce qu'ils ont besoin des
seniors et ça n'empêche pas l'emploi du
jeûne par ailleurs il y a pas que
l'index dans ce qui est pris pour dans
l'article 2 et à côté aussi le fait
d'éviter les ruptures conventionnelles
excessives aujourd'hui il apparaît que
c'est plus facile c'est maintenu de
faire une rupture conventionnelle que
d'aller jusqu'à la retraite donc vous
avez compris qu'il y a des mesures dans
cet article 2 il y a des mesures déjà
qui favorisent le maintien dans l'emploi
des seniors donc le fait qu'aujourd'hui
l'opposition tout entière qui parle des
seniors et qui dans le même temps comme
les républicains aujourd'hui on nous
fait un de leurs sujets majeurs au
moment où il faut voter votre compte il
y a de leur part une incohérence et
plutôt la volonté de montrer qu'ils ne
sont pas la remorque de gouvernement
mais qui peuvent marquer leur différence
peut pas tous les jours demander les
avancées et non obtenu de nombreuses que
nous avons soutenu par ailleurs dans le
même temps se conduire comme cela
aujourd'hui je crois que les Français ne
se retrouvent pas dans une démarche
aussi incohérente et qu'au final c'est
la majorité de droits du Sénat qui va
donner un peu le ton sur cette réforme
de retraite alors que l'examen ne
pourrait pas aboutir à l'Assemblée
nationale finalement est-ce que ce n'est
pas la droite du Sénat qui va écrire
cette réforme des retraites d'abord
j'espère qu'on ira plus loin possible à
l'Assemblée nationale j'espère même
qu'on ira au vote 80 et puis j'espère
jusqu'à l'article 7 de l'âge de ici au
Sénat j'ai cru comprendre que les
républicains veulent être cohérents avec
eux et maintenir leur souhait de
retraite non plus à 65 comme ils l'ont
fait pendant quatre ans mais à 64 voire
63 parfois j'ai vu la volonté du
président Larcher et du président
Retailleau de faire que le texte avance
et que les républicains la votent
j'espère qu'ici il n'y aura pas trop de
nouveaux chantiers ouverts qu'on restera
sur un projet équilibré qui maintient
l'équilibre justement du système des
retraites et permettent je crois ce
système de perdurer merci beaucoup
François Patriat et donc vous le voyez
tamilia une meilleure ambiance entre la
majorité présidentielle et la droite ici
au Sénat merci merci beaucoup Alexandre
tout de suite et bien c'est la fin de ce
débrief on va rejoindre l'Assemblée
nationale pour la suite des débats sur
la réforme des retraites des débats qui
doivent encore se terminer vendredi à
minuit il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'articles encore à discuter on prend
donc tout de suite la direction de
l'assemblée
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour un nouveau numéro
de 100% Sénat à l'émission qui vous fait
vivre les travaux de la Haute Assemblée
la commission d'enquête du Sénat sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments à
auditionner hier d'anciennes ministres
du logement avec cette question comment
se fait-il qu'en 2022 la France compte
5,2 millions de passwords thermiques ces
logements qui ont une trop forte
consommation énergétique et vous allez
le voir à ces auditions ont permis
d'apporter quelques réponses
se trouve donc que j'ai été ministre il
y a plus de 10 ans désormais et que j'ai
arrêté toute activité politique depuis
2017 depuis juin 2017 donc vous m'avez
conduite à me replonger dans quelques
archives mais je voudrais dire ici que
si j'avais fait quelques approximations
notamment sur le plan des chiffres je
m'en excuse bien volonté dont vous je
j'ai juré solennellement et ce serait
donc uniquement des erreurs de date ou
des erreurs de mémoire
d'autant que l'intégralité de mes
archives y compris nos archives
personnelles sont restés et sont à
disposition ministère donc elles sont
parfaitement consultables je voulais
commencer par vous raconter une anecdote
qui je pense est assez illustratif du
sujet sur lequel vous travaillez
j'ai donc été nommé ministre en 2012
juste après l'élection de François
Hollande et quelques semaines après le
nouveau Président je crois que c'était
son titre du programme investissement
d'avenir tout fraîchement nommé Louis
Gallois demande à me rencontrer
évidemment j'accepte et nous avons un
échange sur la fonction des programmes
investissement d'avenir si vous vous
souvenez c'est un programme lancé par
Nicolas Sarkozy après la crise de 2008
un programme de relance massive et une
partie de ce programme devait être
consacrée à la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments le nouveau président me dit
donc que il y avait un budget de 500
millions d'euros consacré à la
rénovation thermique des
habitations des plus démunis et que
malencontreusement ce programme faisait
l'objet d'une sous consommation massive
puisque 5 millions seulement avait été
engagés et que donc il souhaitait
m'informer que
dans le cadre de leur réflexion il
souhaitait réattribuer le reliquat soit
49 millions d'euros à Airbus vous
imaginez que la toute nouvelle ministre
du Logement qui plus est écologiste a eu
un petit moment de fraîcheur à l'annonce
de cette disposition et je lui ai
expliqué que ça allait pas être possible
que je pensais que c'était une erreur
mais que quand même il y avait un sujet
sur cette sous-consommation après
enquête et je résume à gros trait la
sous-consommation s'expliquait assez
naturellement puisque les publics
visaient par ce programme devait
répondre au plafond pls c'est-à-dire
environ 60% du SMIC là encore je vous
dis de mémoire donc on va dire donc des
plafonds assez bas mais pour des
montants de travaux très importants de
lors d'une trentaine de milliers d'euros
donc on comprend très volo très
rapidement que engager des travaux de
plus de 30000 euros quand on a comme
revenu moins de 60% du SMIC forcément
c'est très compliqué
à la suite de ça j'ai organisé une
rencontre avec l'ensemble des
intervenants dans ce domaine là dont les
régions qui étaient mobilisées assez
largement je rappelle qu'à l'époque
c'était avant la réforme il y avait
beaucoup plus de régions qu'aujourd'hui
pour un échange assez intéressant dans
lequel autour de la table chaque
représentante en du monde HLM que de
l'Association des régions de France que
de l'ensemble des élus que
les responsables de l'ADEME de la NA
tout le monde explique que tout va faire
cette bien que tout est parfaitement en
ordre et chacun déroule
on va dire le grand talent avec lequel
ils ont mis en oeuvre des politiques je
leur explique qu'il y a quand même un
sujet c'est que tout semble parfait mais
que visiblement ça marche pas c'est pour
résumer ce qui a été à le guide de mon
action comme ministre pendant ces deux
années et ce qui a fait l'objet donc
d'une première annonce si je ne me
trompe pas en janvier 2013 de ce que
devait être une évolution de des
manières d'intervenir en matière de
rénovation thermique c'est-à-dire non
seulement de mobiliser de l'argent mais
surtout de simplifier et à cet instant
je veux dire que je crois qu'un des
principaux handicaps et donc je vais
donc devancer votre votre question c'est
le morcellement des acteurs en charge du
dossier ça c'est le premier point c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de d'initiatives qui
sont bonnes mais il y a un morcellement
très grand et puis il y a surtout une
capacité de la part de certains acteurs
privés à utiliser de manière très
opportuniste des dispositifs qui en
eux-mêmes notamment les crédits d'impôts
peuvent être intéressant mais qui ont
parfois fait l'objet d'utilisation
complètement détournée ce qui a conduit
le législateur notamment au moment de
l'examen des lois de finances à chaque
fois à être très prudent puisque chaque
parlementaire avait des témoignages
d'abus qui s'appuyait sur des
démarchages parfois un peu agressifs de
personnes dont on isolait dont on change
les fenêtres alors que le toit n'était
pas isolé par exemple ce qui est sur un
plan énergétique parfaitement absurde
donc ce morcellement plus des
dispositifs conçus de manière
je sais pas quel est mon adjectif mais
désordonné peut-être qui chacun prit
individuellement pouvait avoir du sens
mais qui n'était pas coordonnées
conduisait au résultat qu'on connaît et
qu'on connaît d'ailleurs pour une part
toujours c'est-à-dire
une grande limite dans la capacité à
mettre en œuvre un programme de
rénovation thermique
j'ai donc fini par obtenir une sorte de
pacte politique avec le Premier ministre
qui était et donc je réponds aussi la
part anticipation à votre question
est-ce que c'était un outil d'être
ministre de pleine exercice oui d'être
ministre de plein exercice et oui
d'avoir du poids politique j'avais du
poids politique pour deux raisons un je
représentais le seul parti partenaire
presque de la coalition politique qui
existait alors et par ailleurs j'avais
un entraînement particulier qui est que
vous avez pas rappelé que j'étais
secrétaire national du parti écologiste
pendant 6 ans ce qui je pense est fait
partie des meilleurs écoles de
l'entraînement au rapport de force que
qui puisse exister sur le marché de la
politique et que je conseille à tout le
monde mais si j'en crois les autres
personnes que vous allez auditionner
cette école a formé un panel politique
qui maintenant va sur l'ensemble du
spectre politique français quasiment
sans exclusion donc je crois que c'est
une bonne école donc je le dis un mini
de plein exercice une capacité au
rapport de politique au rapport de force
politique et la possibilité obtenir des
arbitrages
temps en terme organisationnel qu'en
termes financier parce que et ce sera la
clé du dispositif et l'histoire assez
rapide puisque dès 2014 les choses se
sont gâtées à montrer que en mettant en
cohérence le dispositif en abondant de
manière extrêmement significative les
fonds de la NA ça avait très bien
fonctionné ça a très bien fonctionné et
pendant très peu de temps puisque comme
et donc là je tiens à le dire de manière
la plus ferme qui soit entre les
annonces financières et la réalité des
crédits notamment du fait des gels qui
sont opérés dès l'été souvent par Bercy
vous avez des situations de crispation
et en regardant mes archives j'ai
retrouvé le nombre de questions y
compris d'ailleurs de vos collègues
sénateurs de question écrite ou de
questions orales de chaque sénateur qui
interroge sur son territoire et sur son
département le fait que il y avait plein
de dossiers en attente et en souffrance
dans les tiroirs de Lana parce qu'il y
avait simplement plus donc l'année 2014
a été très marquante donc pour tout dire
le pacte que j'avais avec le Premier
ministre était simple c'était un montant
très important et si ça marchait
d'abonder ce montant il se trouve que
j'ai quitté le gouvernement pour des
raisons qui n'ont pas avoir avec le
programme de rénovation énergétique mais
d'autres raisons politiques que cet
argent a été très bien dépensé très vite
dépensé beaucoup plus vite que ce qui
était prévu et que au lieu d'être abondé
mais le changement de Premier ministre
est donc obligé il a été il n'a pas fait
l'objet d'abondement et ça a été très
bien dit d'ailleurs notamment par
Valérie létharc qui a été présidente de
Lana et qui connaît parfaitement le
sujet c'est que la restriction de ces
crédits doublés du fait de la baisse
après le brexit du prix du carbone qui a
fait aussi baisser les ressources de
Lana et malgré un amendement pris de 50
millions si je me trompe pas sur le
budget de ce qui se devait s'appeler
déjà Action Logement ou je ne sais pas
encore enfin des crédits de feu en pour
cent logements
des crédit de la nana n'était pas
suffisants pour suivre les engagements
qui avaient été pris
alors nous faisons peu ce genre d'études
en France mais l'étude dont je vous
parle est assez ancienne mais les
Britanniques qui évaluaient les
économies en matière de financement de
l'assurance maladie enfin l'équivalent
de l'Assurance Maladie de
l'investissement dans la rénovation
thermique notamment pour ce qui est des
personnes âgées parce qu'on sait très
bien que la précarité énergétique
au-delà des conséquences sociales de
confort à des conséquences sur la santé
significative et que donc c'est
investissement peut être compensé par
des économies alors je sais qu'on fait
peu ses études et il se trouve que
depuis presque 5 ans maintenant je
travaille dans une organisation qui a
une culture anglo-saxonne donc ça ne
choque moins que ça pourrait choquer des
Français mais sur le bon usage de
l'argent public de voir effectivement ce
que ça peut coûter comme argent mais ce
que ça économise au-delà de l'aspect
moral et satisfaisant d'avancer vers
davantage de justice sociale c'est très
intéressant l'autre élément c'est que
c'est aussi un investissement d'argent
public très rentable puisque les travaux
de rénovation thermique sont une
activité parfaitement
non délocalisable et qui fourni de
l'emploi local donc je ne saurais pas
évalué et je ne sais pas s'il existe des
études publiées sur l'impact d'un euro
d'argent public investi dans la
rénovation thermique en création de
richesse et en diminution du chômage
mais je suis sûr qu'elle serait forte
intéressante à conduire parce qu'elles
sont à mon avis très marquantes autre
élément très important je crois le recul
qui a été pris dans l'investissement des
collectivités locales parce que
évidemment la question des bâtiments et
des logements est importante mais la
question du tertiaire et notamment des
bâtiments publics dans le respect du
patrimoine et dans le respect des
prérogatives des architectes des
bâtiments de France mais néanmoins de
façon très volontariste et pour moi
aussi un élément clé de de levier très
utile et qui a été sous-utilisé là aussi
j'ai mémoire d'une réunion de discussion
extrêmement vive sur l'investissement de
la Caisse des Dépôts possibles pour
aider une collectivités locales à
conduire une vraie politique
d'économie d'énergie un peu plus large
mais aussi de rénovation de leur
patrimoine il faut savoir que beaucoup
de collectivités locales possèdent des
bâtiments construits dans la pire
période la pire période n'étant pas
celle qui est autour de nous mais les
années 70-80 qui ont conduit à
j'ai fâché les années 70 et 80
qui ont conduit à une production de
consommateur
consommateur d'énergie parfois y compris
les systèmes de chauffage qui sont des
systèmes de chauffage eux aussi très
très énergivores donc la conjonction de
ces deux phénomènes à mon point de vue
était un frein important
pourquoi j'en tire une expérience
nuancée d'abord parce que ça s'est
arrêté mais parce que ça a marché c'est
à dire que pendant une cour période il y
a eu vraiment un effet considérable au
sein de la NA alors je pense que vous
pourriez avec intérêt
convié les personnes de Lana qui était
présente à cette époque parce qu'elles
ont un souvenir sans doute plus précis
que le mien mais si je retrouve les
chiffres les le bilan qui avait été tiré
au bout d'un an était très très positif
parce qu'il y avait une appétence forte
et je pense que en le disant presque 10
ans après malheureusement il y aura une
appétence encore beaucoup plus
importante
cette rénovation thermique notamment des
bâtiments des particuliers n'est pas
possible sans l'effet de levier de du
financement public je le crois d'abord à
ce qu'il est un outil de motivation
ensuite parce que il y a un écart entre
le taux d'investissement nécessaire et
le taux de rentabilité qui peut être
beaucoup trop long pour un certain
nombre de personnes physiques ça n'est
pas le cas je le dis pour les personnes
morales que ce soit les entreprises d'où
la question du tertiaire ou les
collectivités locales mais pour les
propriétaires personnes physiques c'est
plus compliqué je pense qu'il y a deux
angles morts
le premier angle mort c'est celui des
propriétaires bailleurs
le dispositif qui permet de contribuer
aux travaux d'économie d'énergie en
échange de du conventionnement Anaï est
un bon dispositif de mon point de vue
mais il serait beaucoup plus efficace
s'il était plus contraignant alors les
avancées législatives vont sans doute le
permettre mais je crains un angle mort
actuel
et là je fais quoi un débat qui était un
débat vif à l'époque ce débat a été
résolu entre les organisations de
protection de l'environnement qui
étaient très volontariste sur l'éviction
n'est pas soit thermique de
l'autorisation de location enfin de les
faire rentrer dans le décret d'essence
qui va arriver avec les logements de
type G mais avec du coup un risque et je
le vois là je puisque votre commission
travaille aujourd'hui je me permets
cette petite alerte c'est à dire que la
vente massive de logements
qui sont plus possibles d'être loués et
qui vont être rachetés uniquement par
des gens qui auront les moyens de
pouvoir investir pour faire ces travaux
pour louer donc pas forcément à un tarif
très intéressant et avec une
concentration du patrimoine locatif qui
est déjà très identifié qui a été très
identifié par l'INSEE et qui à mon avis
est un problème qui dépasse le problème
de la rénovation énergétique mais je
pense qu'en matière de logement et j'y
reviendrai avoir une vision globale des
enjeux et pas de manière sectorisée
entre le prix des loyers le prix du
foncier
la consommation thermique des bâtiments
me paraît être absolument nécessaire
puisque quand on parle de logement on
touche à un sujet qui relève des besoins
fondamentaux de l'être humain comme
boire ou manger on a besoin d'un abri je
crois que
l'intervention de la puissance publique
sur ces sujets et absolument essentiel
dernier élément que je voulais apporter
à votre réflexion
les embarder divers et variés l'absence
de Constance
alors je crois que les objectifs sont
toujours annoncés en étant les mêmes
mais qui sont jamais tenus et donc je
trouve ça très intéressant que vous vous
posiez la question de savoir pourquoi
ils sont pas tenus ils sont pas tenus là
en l'occurrence les objectifs qu'ils
avaient que j'avais annoncé en tant que
ministre ils ont pas été tenus parce que
l'amendement qui avait été promis entre
guillemets par le Premier ministre s'il
dispositif fonctionnel n'a pas été mise
en oeuvre et donc il y a de fait une
restriction et quand vous aboutissez je
pense que ces embarder sont aussi Natura
freiner durablement parce que les gens
pensent que ça va marcher plus que ça va
pas marcher et comme ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie de monter un dossier et
beaucoup de complexité vous avez une
perte en ligne qui est considérable et
au fil des années un épuisement des
acteurs et ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose de nouveau je pense qu'il peut y
avoir un épuisement des acteurs de tous
ceux qui travaillent dans ce domaine du
fait de cette complexité pour s'attaquer
à ce sujet je suis maintenant assez
convaincue qu'il est absolument
nécessaire d'avoir un service public de
la rénovation énergétique
qui est capable d'être un guichet unique
notamment des différents financements
possibles par les différentes
collectivités locales mais aussi
Egyptiens là de fournir une expertise en
matière
énergétique qui soit une expertise
honnête
bien sûr si vous
n'avez pas
une vraie objectivité sur la
priorisation des travaux effectués dans
un logement vous pouvez aboutir à des
aberrations et une dépense d'argent qui
n'aura pas d'effet sur les économies
d'énergie et ça c'est donc quel a été la
réponse du législateur de supprimer tout
un tas de crédits d'impôts ce qui était
positif dans un sens à éviter des abus
négatifs dans un autre parce que ça
pouvait être parfaitement utile donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y a une vision
beaucoup plus
[Musique]
partagée d'un vrai diagnostic et d'une
priorisation des travaux parce que et là
aussi donc une pierre dans le jardin des
écologistes
mes débats de ministres ont été
difficiles avec certaines associations
écologistes qui considéraient que or une
rénovation globale qui aboutissait à un
niveau Bâtiment Basse Consommation
point de salut au sens où de gagner
quelques
pas étaient pas suffisant j'entends sur
un plan théorique que je l'entends bien
mais pour certains c'était en fait le
résultat c'était rien
l'objection justifiée était dire que
certains travaux qui apparaissaient
comme des travaux de rénovation
énergétique j'ai donné tout à l'heure
cet exemple des fenêtres quand le toit
est pas isolé c'était absurde c'est vrai
c'est pour ça que je pense que le
diagnostic énergétique préalable fait de
manière objective et sans que ce soit
ensuite celui qui a intérêt à faire les
travaux qui fasse ce diagnostic et à mon
avis absolument décisif donc et je fais
le lien avec la loi alur beaucoup ont
reproché les abus de diagnostic
préalable aux ventes de logement je
pense que s'ils sont bien faits c'est au
contraire très utile parce que avant
oui oui bien sûr je pense que avant
excusez-moi
on faisait
acquérir des biens à des personnes qui
se rendaient compte au bout de quelques
mois qu'en fait elle pouvait tout
simplement pas payer le chauffage de
leur de leur habitation qui se
retrouvaient surendettée des dans les
semaines ou les mois qui suivaient leur
acquisition en n'ayant pas eu
connaissance du tout de l'ensemble de
ces éléments et que quand vous engagez à
acheter un bien évidemment le coup du
prêt mais il y a bien d'autres dépenses
qui n'étaient pas du tout évaluées je le
rappelle avant la loi alur donc au titre
des fiertés et je le dis de manière très
très modeste parce que c'est
recommandations n'étaient pas ne sont
pas sorties de de mon cerveau mettez
l'objet j'avais fait l'objet de rapport
parlementaire et de propositions d'un
certain nombre de parlementaires tant à
l'Assemblée qu'au Sénat je pense que
c'est ce sont de bonnes avancées mais
que maintenant il faut aller un pas plus
loin et je pense que or ce guichet
unique or cette interlocuteur simple on
n'arrivera pas à massifier les objectifs
de rénovation thermique le deuxième
élément c'est un élément de financière
donc je sais que c'est plus à la mode
les lois de programmation
sauf quand elles sont dans un cas de
militaire mais je pense que si on veut
lancer des grands travaux qui perdent
nous permettent à la fois à la
transition énergétique et de essayer de
tenir notre
SNBC mais aussi de pouvoir se préparer à
l'adaptation nécessaire à laquelle nous
allons devoir faire face du fait du
changement climatique il faut absolument
une loi de programmation qui sécurise
pour l'ensemble des acteurs comme pour
les particuliers
une trajectoire dans la durée je suis
absolument résolue parce que l'échec de
ce qui a été annoncé par la ministre
Cécile Duflot en 2013 il est écrit dans
une réponse à une question
au Sénat que je vais vous retrouver qui
dit de manière très claire que les
crédits de la de Lana ont été gelés au
mois de juin de l'année 2014
et que du coup les objectifs qui avaient
été achetés même les dossiers qui
existaient dans les tiroirs de Lana ne
pouvaient pas être mise en oeuvre donc
voilà c'est finalement assez simple ça
semble complexe c'est pas si complexe
mais comme toutes les politiques
d'ampleur je pense qu'elle nécessite